Riyle justical's editor retweets bad empanada and posts his stuff
in other subreddits about empanada docs a few days ago how it's
that we can put them all together we can all we can connect it
all so rile was bad empanada the whole time apparently our our
good friend of the stream logic is allowing a bunch of doxing
and degenerate to happen in spicy chat right oh I don't like
that word consent violator what no I'm not a consent violator
I have a gooner lifestyle guys I don't I don't just like habitually
ually violate consent. I have a gooner lifestyle. Man, I'm really
scared that she might be underage cuz that's the only thing that'll
sink me here. I can sweep the rest of it away. I can sweep the
rest of it away. But if she's under if she's under 18, I can't
sweep that away. All VTubers/ streamers who use those bouncy
cartoon rant sonas need to be put into camps now.
Okay, so Destiny went over a bunch of his like lawsuit stuff
today. went over some thoughts on like doxing and
uh it's okay. It's whatever. But I'm I'm going to cover that.
We'll see. We'll see how it goes.
Where I have the link here. Where I Where's the link at?
Where' I put it? Destiny.
Okay, cool.
Okay. It starts somewhere around here. He first starts talking
about his legal cases and
starts talking about the legal cases and then he slowly like
weaves into talking about like doxing and stuff and it's just
crazy to me that nobody in his audience asks for any evidence
of any of the things he says. He just gets to like make things
up and then even when they do ask for evidence, it'll be like
this person
this person is guilty of murder or something is what he'll say.
Okay, this is a hypothetical. This person's guilty of murder
and people go wait is there evidence of that? and he'll go, "Yeah,
I have a picture of them in the hotel where the person was murdered
that day." And they'll go, "Oh, yeah, they are guilty of murder,
aren't they?" Oh my god, Destiny. Destiny just proved they're
guilty of murder. And it's like, "No, he didn't. He proved that
they're like in the same hotel as the as the person who got What
are you saying? How do you lose all critical thinking capability
when it's Destiny saying it like one tiny piece of evidence with
no other connection, right?
It's it's wild. Anyway, so we'll have stuff like that. That'll
be coming up."
>> This is a quick meme because I saw some people discussing
this.
>> My best friend was on uh Twitter yesterday
having an epic. >> We talked about the Abby thing. Yeah.
Uh Abby posted some stuff on Twitter and then deleted her account.
I was like >> people are arguing whether or not you have
to respond to a subpoena um for a civil case. So one generally
they require some kind of response.
You don't always have to respond to a subpoena, but obviously
if you give an affidavit, you that's literally a part of that
affidavit is that you're willing to testify in court. Um, but
people are talking about whether you have to be involved in a
case or if it's your choice or what not. The thing is is that
this is not like a random person who's being subpoenaed to join
the case. This is somebody who has filled out an affidavit. They've
attached a declaration swearing that they would testify to this
in court. So yes, they do have to make themselves available for
deposition. You cannot
you can't like um you can't say something fill out an affidavit
attack. >> This is just this is just true that you can't
fill out an affidavit and then refuse to appear in court. That's
not how that works. I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure part of the
affidavit is you saying I will show up and testify to these facts
in in a court of law. Now they can ask to depose. I'm not totally
sure about depositions or what that means exactly if that's like
before a jury. I I don't know the exact way that works out. I
would assume you should be able to depose them as the opposing
side, but >> it to some lawsuit and then dodge service
or subpoena until the day of the trial and then just show up
like we have a right to depose um an opposing person. Also, just
as a heads up too, um not that this matters and this is all just
federal rules of civil procedure, I still don't have like half
the that these losers have filed to the court. Um they haven't
made any of it available to us. all of those things that you
see where they've got like redacted names and for like half of
these I've never gotten an original that's been sent to
>> Okay. So, first of all, he's saying I've never gotten
an original that was sent to me. So, I assume what happened was
they were doing the the ceiling. Okay.
I would I would be very curious there if Destiny has not gotten
it sent to him, but if it's been sent to his lawyer,
So, he's saying, "Oh, they haven't sent anything to me." I believe
the protective order they're filing for is so that they don't
have to give you names, right? I think that's the goal is they
don't want to give you names.
Mr. Mutton back in DG. I don't care. I'm not talking about Mr.
Moot. Okay. Um
I believe that's the whole point of the protective order is so
they don't have to give you names so that Andrew can get them
but you shouldn't get them. That's like the entire purpose, right?
So I would imagine they're not sending you those names while
the order or while the filing for the protective order is
Um I like it's just which you're not allowed to do. It's not
you're not allowed to do that. It's violating the rules of civil
procedure. But yeah, this was funny. I don't know why she admitted.
Well, probably she didn't realize it was probably not a good
thing to do. But why didn't the judge if it's violating the rules
of civil procedure? Why didn't the judge mention it to them?
Can they get away with that though? No. But I don't They're not
trying to like
Can they get away with that though? The Yes. You literally got
mocked by their lawyer who said, "Obviously, we didn't violate
rules of civil procedure on this because nobody cares."
They The lawyer took the time to mock you in the filing.
What are we talking about? Can they get away with this? Uh, can
they get away? I assume if Abby won't testify anywhere at all,
then her her testimony will be inadmissible.
It's not about getting away with Nobody's getting away with something.
People are like looking at this as a case that they're trying
to win, but they're not trying to win it. They're just trying
to drag this out as much as possible. Like it wouldn't surprise
me if they got a bunch of bad rulings on these upcoming motions.
If they did, that they would like dismiss the case. Like I have
no faith in them actually handing over like what we've asked
for in Discovery. I don't think they'll do it. Um, and if they
do, I think they'll hide and obscure stuff.
>> So now Destiny, Destiny basically was of the opinion
that when he is the only person holding his logs, when he deletes
all of his logs and he's the only person holding them, that that
means nothing bad happened, right? Guys, I would never edit these
things. And now he's doing the same thing back, he's like, "Oh,
actually, even if they give us the stuff that like we subpoenaed,
well, I think that would all be like edited and changed and and
they delete stuff."
>> um, I don't think they're even trying to win at trial.
I think they're just doing everything they can to survive the
motion for summary judgement so that they can drag it out. >> They
want to go to discovery. This, by the way, this case has always
and forever been about going to Discovery to get evidence from
Google or Discord that the video has been sent again, right?
Like that's been what it's been about the entire time. Hey, we
need we need a a suit so we can go to Google and Discord and
see if you've sent this video, Pixie. That's the entire purpose
of the suit, right?
Hey, this is outside of uh this is outside but we have people
willing to testify that you sent these things right within the
within the Cardi statute limit uh not statute limit but after
Cardi was passed
this we're just looking to get to discovery. We want to get to
discovery and then we're going to subpoena your records from
Discord and Google and then we'll just see what happens. Right.
Like like basically if you didn't send it then I guess we we
lose our federal jurisdiction or whatever. But that's been the
entire thing. They just want to go to Discovery.
Yes.
right? Based on, hey, we have people saying that you sent this
video to them. We want to go to Discovery and see if that's if
that's a thing that happened.
It's not confusing,
right? Pixie was wronged. Are we Are we pretending that you didn't
say you violated her trust in the worst possible way? Are we
pretending that she wasn't wronged? She's absolutely wronged.
And now she's like, "I believe you've wronged me again. Here's
my evidence for that. Here's people who are saying that you wronged
me again. I want to charge you under this law and and look for
this in discovery." out as long as like I think that's it.
>> So the idea that they want to survive summary judgement
is obvious. That's been
what what plaintiff doesn't want to survive summary judgement
before going to trial.
Did you guys know Listen this is this is Destiny POV. Okay. Destiny
I'll do my Perry impression. Destiny Destiny Destiny be like
Destiny be like uh oh Destiny play soccer. Desi's playing soccer.
Okay, guys. Dessi's playing soccer. And when the other team tries
to score on him, he says, "Oh, look at them trying to score on
me and win the game. I'm being wronged."
Okay, that's what's happening. They're literally playing by the
rules. They're doing exactly what they're supposed to do. And
he's like, "I'm being wronged. I am now a victim."
Come on, man.
I got to work on my Perry impression.
It could be better. I think it's more incompetence than intentional.
No, it is intentional. It's not incompetence. It is intentional.
The Zabby person is like pretty clearly like mentally unwell
and they absolutely roped her in with
Wait,
it's pretty clearly mentally unwell. Wait, why did you invite
her to your home and leave her with all of your stuff apparently
unlocked
if she's so clearly mentally unwell?
How many How many times in a row could you make the same excuse?
Okay, bro.
Take a shot. Take a shot. Take a shot. Zabby person is like pretty
clearly like mentally unwell and they absolutely roped her in
with like an absolute
They roped her in with an absolute claim. Where is the Abby has
been consistent in her testimony the entire time. The exact testimony
that she provided is the testimony that she can provide, right?
Like is the evidence she can provide. There's no there's nothing
in her testimony from her affidavit. He keeps lying about this.
He just lies, right? He's just openly lying. She said she has
contemporaneous evidence of you sharing it. As in she told other
people about it, right? She told other people that you shared
these videos with her from that time from before she could know
that the video's existence and she said your side of the logs
were deleted, but she could provide her side of the
What's confusing? That's been the whole time. That's been what
she said she has. Why would Destiny if that's not enough to survive
summary judgement or if that's like a problem, right? Or sorry,
if that's not a problem and that's, you know, not evidence of
anything, then what is he mad about? That's all she claimed.
Like, you have to know how it is if you're trying to rope in
a witness who is literally telling you I I literally can't prove
anything that I'm saying right now. And
what what does he think she tried to
He again like you could you could make this argument if you're
really dumb. You can make this argument, right? She didn't pro
she doesn't have, you know, exported Discord logs of the exact
videos that are at play here. You could say that, but that's
never been their claim or her claim or anyone's claim. So, you're
fighting against a total straw man that you're making up.
Why Why do you even care about this? If it's all like total like
proof of nothing, if it all means nothing, then shouldn't the
court just decide that in your fa in your favor? And also I might
have gone through his entire computer and there might be like
photographic evidence of me doing that when I was at his house.
Like
oh
also I went through notice also I went through his computer and
there may be photographic evidence of me doing that at his house.
This is this is I it might not be the first instance but this
is an instance of guys I have evidence Abby murdered somebody.
The evidence is Abby having a picture a photo in the hotel where
the person was murdered that day. Right?
So, if you want to know evidence that she went through my computer
is this precisely. Hold on, let me let me grab this.
This is uh I can find this in another tab real quick. This is
I I saw this in the tweet thread with Ellie B and the other people
the other day.
So, evidence that she went through my computer is that she posted
a photo in in this with Darius. Okay. Not to big any big not
to any big stream plans. Are you already on the way home? Apparently,
this is to Darius. Okay. Now I'm chilling in Destiny's apartment
until my flight he left. Soon though, I'm him. Major leaks prob.
So major leaks problem. And she posts this. She's like, "Oh,
this is a picture of his computer."
I have no evidence she went through anything on this computer.
One wonders why you would leave somebody who you think is clearly
mentally ill with your computer unlocked like right after a stream,
right? He clearly just finished streaming, but she's sitting
in his chair looking at his computer and saying, "Oh, I might
be leaking stuff on his computer by taking a picture of this."
Right? His Discord's open. This stuff's open. There's no evidence
she went through any of this.
I see no evidence. And and the thing I'd just be curious about
is so we're going to get to this later where he says he says
major leagues pro. What is what is after this? If you have all
these logs, why aren't there more logs here? Where are the rest
of the logs? Are you saying that she just sat there and did nothing?
I'm saying I don't know what she did, but clearly she's saying
major leagues Prague. Shouldn't there be major leaks
If that's what your assertion is, she's going to go through his
computer and leak a bunch of things. She's going to go through
his computer.
Where's the rest of the messages?
Why don't we have those? Didn't she admit to Darius that she
went through it? Or am I misremembering? Well, this is the evidence
that she admitted to Darius that she went through it or something.
I don't see the other evidence. She might have. I have no idea.
I'm just saying that when he says she did that, she admitted
she did that. I don't think she did. And this is the evidence
I've been shown so far.
And it's this picture.
Now, I have no idea what Abby did. Apparently, and I don't think
Abby denies it. Apparently, she took a picture of some Molina
journal or something, which seems like a violation of privacy,
right?
But I don't I don't see any evidence that she went through this
and saw like the things that you're claim like a video pixie
or something. By the way, the video Pixie couldn't possibly be
here, could it? Where did she go? Where where would it show up
here?
The video Pixie was sent like a year earlier or something, right?
The video pixie sent a year earlier. Why would it be anywhere
here at all?
What would you need her saying? I went through his What do you
mean? I I would need her saying I went through his computer looking
for stuff, but I would also need some evidence that she saw the
pixie video. Where would the pixie video be? Here
is that Discord. I literally pointed to the Discord being open.
I'm assuming if she's looking to leak stuff, if she's snooping
on his computer, that she would have said something about it.
She doesn't say anything about what could what he alleges could
be there until 2 months
But there are people here like Lexer Q who has a impression in
his brain. He's totally right. Totally. There are people like
this guy who are like, "No, no, no. Desi says uh Desi says this
happened." Destiny says he found these videos by looking at his
Discord or something.
Didn't Abby say something about Abby has testified to precisely
this? Hold on. Do I have I think I have her testimony here
This is a Bretler testimony. Do I have her testimony somewhere
here? Let me find the Dabby testimony here. Hold on.
Uh, where's witness A here?
Let me find this. What she what she testifies to is she says
she was sent videos by him, right? That's what that's what's
sent. Where is it? Where is it? Where is it?
I'll find it. Don't worry.
Oh my god.
Witness A and B.
Oh my god. Is Sya here? If Cyber is here, I would take this.
But I don't see I literally don't see these exhibits on their
behalf right now.
I'm blind.
Give me a second.
Plaintiff's declaration.
It's not this one. No, here it is. Oh, here it is. I found it.
Right.
Yes. Okay.
This is it. This is all Aby's ever claimed. Okay. We're going
to go through exactly what Aby's claimed. All right. On her about
November 3rd, 2023, Destiny shared through a Google Drive link
a explicit video that included himself and another streamer,
Pixie, the plaintiff in this action. I recognized Pixie in the
video because I had seen her post on Instagram and had seen her
on Destiny's live streams and on her own live
her face and hair or her face and hair is visible in the video
and that is how I recognized her honor about no so I was sent
this video on about November 20 uh 3rd 2023 I messaged a friend
of mine and said that I've been sent this video okay
and then here it's like I recently reviewed my Discord account
and realized Destiny deleted all of his direct messages to me
on the Discord platform including the sharing of the video Pixie
I retained copies of all of my messages as well as my messages
to other people about his non-consensual sharing of explicit
videos this is what she said she had
Okay. So, Destiny tells people that she claimed she had proof
that he sent this. She didn't. She said, "I have contemporaneous
evidence of this and I have my side of the logs because he has
deleted his logs."
That's that's the claim.
It's like not confusing to anyone what she's claimed. Right.
But he he pretends that Abby came and said, "I have proof that
he sent this to me. I have like like shot proof." No, but the
question is is how does Abby tell people in 2023
that these things that won't be leaked until late 2024 exist?
How does she know about the existence of a Pixie video?
How does she tell people about it?
How is she able to do that?
All right, hold on. Let me see.
This is This is what she did. She told a friend here. By the
way, Destiny sends me tapes all the time and he thinks I don't
know the girls in them, but I have videos of him Cherry and Pixie
like Lafoul. He just sent me another one. Haven't opened it.
Let's see who's this time. This is what she said, right?
Same reason Lav did. It was just a good guess. Clueless. Yeah,
exactly.
But the cherry vid, isn't it sound only? So, she said this back
here, right? But she said in the testimony that it's sound only.
She said in the testimony by just by her voice because it's a
black screen with audio.
So she says in the testimony that it was
but I don't the the cherry thing is not even relevant to this
case, right? I thought I thought Destiny's whole point is the
cherry thing isn't relevant to this case. Why would he even look
at that? Why would we just look at the pixie thing? How does
How does she know the Pixie thing exists?
Can anybody tell me? How does she know the pixie thing exists?
Lexer Q, I want you to tell me how she knows the Pixie thing
exists.
Go ahead.
I just want to I just want to see what he says. I just want to
see.
Looked it up on his PC. How did he look it How did she look it
up on his PC? It wasn't shared with anybody. It was shared with
uh Destiny in like 2019. He would have had years of logs between
that with Pixie, right? Where did he look? Where did she look
it up? Where was that video sitting that apparently Abby found
it within seconds on his PC?
I I'm literally I can grant you this insane assertion that she
went through his PC or all of his Discord messages or something
and you still can't explain this because you're a [__]
and you believe everything he tells you without any actual intellectual
curiosity or any internal monologue or any ability to discern
fact from fiction.
Sad. Sad. Point and laugh at Luxer Q. He is sad.
Anyway, what's the what's the next
What's the next thing? We go back to this video. Yeah. So, he
just made up. He just says, "Oh, she she said that she looked
through his whole computer and uh Oh, and also there's like evidence
of >> I might have gone through his entire computer and
there might be like photographic evidence of me doing that when
I was at his house." Like, you know, that >> we just looked
at the photographic evidence apparently.
Like if this does go if it were to go to trial, like imagine
that person on the witness stand, right? So you've given like
three different testimonies about what it is that you even saw
or was sent here because initially she said like she saw videos
of like me and these these three testimonies. She says in here
that it's a black video. She might have had it maybe it was saved
as like an MP4 file but it was just the audio or something, right?
Like we have no idea on that front at all. But that's not really
like
I don't need that to be like totally accurate or that it's a
video of this person. I don't know how it's even I don't even
know how this is like a um like a talking point. She's referencing
things that she should have no idea >> These videos don't
even exist. I've never known these at all. But she can be like, "Well,
I misspoke there." And I was like, "Okay, well in your declaration
you said that he sent you these things." It's like, "Okay, yeah."
And it's like where? >> Yes. Okay.
So three different things, three things that are incompatible
that she received videos of Cherry. Okay, that's maybe that's
maybe okay. Maybe. Also, she said she testified that you sent
her these things. That's apparently an incompatible statement.
How >> were you or were you not in his apartment
um taking pictures of >> Oh. Oh, he's going to pretend
to be the lawyer. Hold on. Let's see how he walks this down in
terms of questioning. >> Were you or were you not in his
apartment
um taking pictures of his computer? It's like, well,
>> yes, I took a picture of his computer to show that I
was in his apartment. this streamer, this famous streamer that
I just Yep. took a picture to show that I was in his apartment.
Yep. >> Yeah. Is there a chance you saw stuff then? I don't
know.
>> No, I don't know. No, I don't recall seeing anything
then. What do you mean when you texted Darius? Major leaks incoming.
Well, >> oh, so she texted that to Darius and Darius has
additional texts here. So, why don't we just ask Darius what
Major Leaks probs means, right? What did you mean when when she
texted Major League P?
If if she meant I'm going to leak things off of his computer
instead of just I'm leaking his screen right now,
why don't we just get those additional texts from Darius?
Can someone explain that to me why we wouldn't just get those
additional texts from Darius showing all this malfeasants or
something?
Can anybody explain that to me?
I would just love to
like you have to you have to literally suck this guy off to be
anywhere near right at all trying to believe this
stuff then I don't know what do you mean when you texted Darius
major leaks incoming well I was just joking
and then I can produce both >> well I was just joking I
would just say did she leak things
you can you can know what her intent was you just see what she
did >> both of our logs on my side So there's like it's
like this is like it's
>> dude dude dude
you can see both of our logs on my side because what if you deleted
your logs? What do you mean? If I delete all my logs with somebody
and go actually I have both of our logs downloaded and they only
have one side. Doesn't that mean they're just Can't we say that
they're untrustworthy? Guys, no.
What?
Guys, I deleted I deleted all the logs on my side and now I have
I have retained copies of both. I can show both sides. Can they?
No.
Darius, major leaks incoming. Well, I was just joking.
And then I can produce both of our logs on my side. So there's
like it's like this is like it's they know that it's he he he
realized halfway through that. Okay. Halfway through that he
realized he wasn't cooking at all. that he was saying something
totally nonsensical he had no point to make and he's a complete
[__] and so he just goes so anyway so to suffice
to say >> our logs on my side so there's like it's like
this is like it's they know that it's like you just slow down
and listen to this guy and you actually just hear that he he's
not even thinking in a straight line. He's totally disregulated.
He's totally disabled. He's not thinking in a straight line at
all. Right.
So it's not. >> So you can just tell it's all
So you can basically just tell it's all
>> here. I'll let it I'll play it the whole way through.
We'll just we'll just listen to him the whole way. >> It
is that you even saw or was sent here because like trial like
that right now. >> And also I might have computer and there
might be like photographic evidence of me doing that when I was
at his house. Like you know that on like if this does go if it
were to go to trial >> from if it were to go to trial guys
this is how it would go. Imagine that person on the witness stand.
Right. So, you've given like three different testimonies about
what it is that you even saw or was sent to because initially
she >> No, actually the testimony I've given is all compatible
with itself.
>> A video file that had a black screen and that's why
it would be audio. By the way, Destiny very obviously obviously
repeatedly saying he recorded audio just to be clear. >> He
said like she saw videos of like me and Cherry Fighting. These
these videos don't even exist. I've never done these at all.
But she can be like, "Well, I misspoke there." And I was like,
"Okay, well, in your declaration, you said that he sent you these
things." It's like, "Okay, yeah." And it's like,
>> she said she was sent that stuff, but if it was a audio,
would that not still >> Were you were you not in his apartment
um taking pictures of his computer? It's like, well, yeah. Is
there >> So, you you said you were sent videos and later
clarified that it was of a black screen and you were in his apartment.
This proves that you are >> Chance you saw stuff then?
I don't know. What do you mean when you texted Darius major leaks
incoming? Well, I was just
and then I can produce both of our logs on my side. >> Oh,
and he can and he because he deleted his side of the logs and
archive first, he can produce both sides of the logs. These things
together, the testimonies that aren't three different testimonies
and don't don't cut each other off at all. Okay, the picture
and the texts
and the fact that he deleted his own logs and could produce both
sides prove that everything's totally made up.
But it doesn't answer the question of, "Hey Destiny, how in 2024,
sorry, in 2023, is Abby aware of a Pixie video that later becomes
public that you said you haven't sent to anybody else?"
How? You could say it's through your computer, then how where
was it on your computer? How? How?
And were you sending a bunch of videos to this Abbeby person?
So there's like it's like this is like it's they know that it's
f there's any evidence of her spying on your computer. It's got
to be in those Darius texts, right? Wouldn't it just be in those
Darius texts?
Could we just can we just go?
He can provide both sides of the logs. Can he show that they
were never sent? I assume so.
>> Isn't that said? So it's not I I believe Abby or sorry
I believe Ellie B asked him about this. just to the stress. It's
not like an accident and it's not um it's not them like making
mistakes. It's they're intentionally like playing game. It's
they're just using the court to do the PR stuff basically. >> So
he he's saying court is for PR here. Okay, that will be interesting.
I'll address that in just a second, but I just want to make it
clear. He's saying Aby's clearly lying. Her testimony has been
in uh inconsistent. All the testimony has been 100% consistent
with all of the evidence provided by Abby. Okay. The the only
thing they cast out in this is her sitting in front of that computer.
All I would say is just let Darius leak the rest of the texts.
Do you have the Darius text so we can revisit exactly what she
told them? Are there are the Darius texts out there? Where are
the rest did Darius leaked more of his texts with her? Not the
Discord logs, but did Darius leak more of that text conversation?
Cuz I would just love to know what else is in there that apparently
they're leaks. Cuz here's the thing. If Abby like told Darius
like, "Oh, I went through his computer and I found like a video
of Pixie." And and I would want that just to be out there. I
don't want I don't want this guy I don't want this guy to like
I don't want people to make things up about this guy and then
he goes to he gets sued or something or he loses in court. I
want him to be I want him to lose in court because of the truth,
I don't need I don't want anything to be made up about him or
him to get totally wrapped in court.
So Aby's testimony is not consistent.
And you have to answer the question of how she's aware of the
pixie thing in 2023. If in September, okay, here's the other
thing. If it's in September, she sees these September 5th, why
does she wait 2 months to mention it to anybody?
Can somebody explain that one to me, too? She apparently waits
two months to mention it to anyone,
but you're arguing that she's going to leak stuff.
Very strange. Very strange stuff. I the inconsistencies
pile up.
>> Anyway, back to this. Oh god, he just said, "Dude, I
>> He lies so densely. I can't even get through the vod."
>> It's not just to stress. It's not like an accident and
it's not um >> It's not them like making mistakes. It's
They're intentionally like playing games. It's They're just using
the court to do the
>> Has Abby proven her allegations? Uh yes. She's literally
proven them to us in the filings. But you're too engage today,
Alexa. So, you're going to go for a little bit. Bye-bye.
Just go look at the filing. She's shown evidence of the things
she said. Unless you think for some reason she doesn't have her
text messages with Destiny on her side.
The only thing that we haven't seen is her all of her logs from
Destiny's side or from her side, right? But consequentially consequently,
we could also just say, well, Destiny should provide all of his
logs. No. Why doesn't he just show us exactly what was sent or
exactly what happened here? Cuz realistically, without his side
of it, it's just going to be Abby saying things. There's no reason
to believe it would be positive or dispositive of anything else
said with just her side of the logs.
>> uh PR stuff basically. >> Oh, Pixie just running
PR stuff against him. That seems insane to me, right? Pixie clearly
has valued her privacy, wants her privacy respected through this
whole thing. That's like been her number one thing. She wants
her privacy respected, right? That's literally she's filing this
case because her privacy was
And not only that, Destiny literally hired the PR lawyer. He
hired the lawyer who costs double what other good lawyers cost
because he wants to run his own PR
Destiny is leaking everything except the evidence that would
exonerate him. Right. He'll leak anything. He'll leak anything
to denigrate anybody, but he will not he will not release evidence
exonerating him.
Shocking. Absolutely shocking.
Destiny doesn't want to produce any logs that exonerate him.
He likes spending money on lawyers and keeping the case
He likes putting Andy Bee's kids through college. Okay? He likes
buying a new Lambo for Andy B. He literally got the most expensive
lawyer in this field who exclusively makes sure that your PR
is spared. He has said precisely. He has said precisely,
I don't care if I lose this. I can't lose in the court of public
opinion. That's more important. I don't care about losing in
court. I don't want to lose in the court of public opinion. He
has said this
And now he's complaining about Pixie doing a PR thing.
You can the United States help pay off the national debt. Beed
based
based.
Is there any downside for them doing this? Um, theoretically
the downside is court cost and reputation. Uh, Pixie has no reputation
and I think that they're working pro bono a family. Wait, what
was that? Is there any downside for them doing this?
Is there any downside? Uh, publicizing the case. Um, spending
a bunch of money on lawyers. Yeah, there's a bunch of downsides.
All of the harass all the online harassment she's getting. Basically,
a ton of her fan base are people who are fans of Destiny first
and her second, right? She's basically saying, "Okay, well, the
whole influencing thing I was kind of working on, I'm willing
to throw that away." Right? There are a bunch of downsides for
her. Are they as steep as Steven's downsides? Maybe not.
Um, theoretically, the downside is court cost and reputation.
Uh, Pixie has no reputation. And >> she absolutely has
a reputation that you've been sullying all over the internet.
The are you saying? >> I think that they're working pro
bono. W's a family friend is my guess. >> Working pro bono.
Evidence. Evidence. keep she he keeps saying Joan Schlump Peters
is a family friend. Evidence, any evidence, anything showing
this? Any reason to believe this? Anything? Any anything and
literally any evidence would be nice. So,
he's saying Joan's a family friend. He said that the whole time.
Do you think that their goal is to just survive to trial and
hope a jury sympathizes with Pixie more than they might be swayed
by the emotional
like not to sound like an but the problem is that the real world
is not like oh this guy who's also tweeting about doing secret
recordings and tweeting about doing secret recordings tweeting
about kids like dead kids not to be an
guys I know I just tweeted about how funny it was that those
Texas kids died but like not to be an
to be an guys
Um, this sounds so mean to say. I don't mean to be mean like
this, but the real world is is not the same as the online world.
Like, in the real world, >> tell me more about the real
world, Destiny. Tell me more about the real world, Destiny. I
This is who I come to for my takes about the real world.
The guy who looks like he has muscular distrophe. 100%. Real
world takes coming in from Destiny right now. I honestly doubt
he's able to lift these rifles
at fault. Like women are hardcore shamed still in the real world.
Like a jury is probably going to be more sympathetic to me than
they are to her. I know everybody has this fantasy in >> you
think so this guy is a blah blah but they're not going to see
that.
>> They're not going to see that. I advise Destiny to show
up to court. Okay. Because the
the defender aura coming off of you with this haircut and goatee
is astronomical. Okay. They can detect this from Mars. Your defender
aura is crazy with this comb over. Okay. Do you think we can't
recognize the haircut, bro? Just cuz you got a goatee instead
of the little pencil mustache. We recognize the haircut. I don't
know why you thought this was a good look. I don't know why you
thought this was a good idea. All right. But you look you look
disconcerting. The average person when they look at you, they
get like an uncanny valley feeling.
The jury will absolutely feel that. I'm very excited for this
to go to trial. Okay.
I'm very excited. They're going to see, oh, there's a girl who
recorded videos with a guy where she sent videos of her and her
boyfriend to this guy and he sent videos of him and his wife
to this girl and you know they've been doing all this trading
around
trading around. No, not trading around. Hold on, dude. From the
very beginning, this has been the story. I
pixie shared with her boyfriend. You said I believe Destiny said
this. I tell girls that Molina has access to my stuff. So like
she'll probably see anything that gets sent to me. He said this
himself.
That doesn't mean you have because you say, "Oh, my wife has
access to my stuff, so she might see this." That doesn't mean
you have you have license to share it to whoever you want. Just
like Pixie when she tells you she's doing this because her boyfriend's
like into it or whatever the right doesn't mean you have access
opportunity to share it with whoever. That doesn't make any sense.
And then she was sort of like you really think a juryy's going
to stand up like oh my god this is like horrible like that that's
a this is like an online position of like everybody is a a yasider
most
then she like you really think a juryy's going to say like oh
my god this is like horrible like that that's a this is like
an online position of like everybody is a a yaslider most people
especially like older people geners and and older are going to
look at it and be like oh wow these are some horny stupid kids.
These are some crazy wacky kids doing. >> No, that's not
it's not going to look like that. And by the way, what they're
also going to do is you're going to take all the tweets where
you're making fun of Pixie yourself or making fun of Pixie saying
you like record things secretly. They're going to look at all
of these tweets. They're going to look at her crying and they're
going to look at you looking like a not actually a just looking
like a and they're going to sympathize with her. Obviously, you're
barely human. And most people will be able to pick that up from
you immediately that you are barely human. doing some stupid.
These are just some crazy kids doing some crazy.
He said kids. He is sounding like one.
Yeah, dude. His his that's that's actually breaking his chat.
Kids unc pushing 40. Mind you, that's that's bad enough when
he refers to himself as a kid that his own chat's going to go,
"Yo, I get, dude, I believe you on everything else. You're totally
being persecuted here." But like, don't refer to yourself as
a kid, okay? With that haircut and that goat teeth. Do not do
not refer to yourself as a kid.
How can you ever go to trial in federal court when the subject
matter jurisdiction isn't even there? Well, they're trying to
Abby lets them push the subject matter jurisdiction issue by
saying that we have somebody. It's not just Abby that lets them
push the subject matter jurisdiction issue, right? Subject matter
uh sorry, subject matter uh what is it? If you file for summary
judgement,
basically there have to be no FA facts at in contention anymore.
There obviously are facts in contention, right? The question
his chat asks are so funny. They're obviously the bi obvious
with the bias. Yes.
But I don't think that's the only thing that pushes it. There's
still like a factual dispute that might have to be argued before
a jury about the time stamps. Now, I personally think that's
insane. I personally think it's obvious that the time stamps
are when they are. Okay.
But there's also what is there? There's one other thing. There's
the idea of continuous publishing that might have to be heard
in front of a judge with all the relevant facts presented, right,
with arguments. So, like those aren't the only things that that
keep this case going. There are still many facts in dispute here.
Somebody who's willing to testify that um he sent her a video
in 2023 or whatever. That's the that's her testimony.
Now, how is a judge? The the question will come down to >> her
testimony is I he sent me a video in 2023. I don't have the logs
of him sending me the video, but I do have the logs of me describing
the video at question in this trial to people in 2023 after he
sent it to me. So, that is the best I can do. But that's I hope
enough for you guys to consider like letting this case go to
trial or I hope that's like I hope this is valuable to you. um
for a summary judgement. The question will come down to whether
or not a judge looks at that and says there is an actual factual
material dispute. There's a material dispute in fact that and
that technically can only be resolved in front of a jury um or
judge if it's a bench or a judge trial. But
but I don't know how conservative or how
liberal not like in a political sense like judges look at evidence
like that.
that alleged transmission to Abby wasn't connected to the leaks
that resulted on Kiwi Farms, right? Um, correct?
Yeah. And then there's the whole question of even like damages
because
Destiny, how can this case go to trial when all these people
are lying about
How does how does a judge not dismiss this out of hand? It's
so clear. They're all working against you. Destiny, Destiny,
Destiny, Destiny, please tell me how how come you haven't filed
your counter suits yet, Destiny. They're all working against
you. It's a conspiracy. They're defaming you. Destiny, why aren't
your counter suits firing off
I can't I need I want to read the transcript. When they go over
at the end of the um hearing when they when the because they're
trying to argue for why they also have the cyber harassment thing
included and then the judge is arguing with them about foreseeability
and the judge is like well how is it that you can say this person
did this with like malicious intent and like well anytime you
send a video like that you have to accept that it could end up
That would be a really stupid argument. I don't know why her
lawyers would have made that argument. That's obviously a argument.
And then the judge is like,
"Isn't that exactly what your client did?"
And they're like, "Well,
there's no way." So that is true. That would be really bad. If
Pixie's lawyers just stopped arguing there, that would be very
very very embarrassing. No,
because realistically, the next question is, and it's it's like,
okay, so she sent it to her boyfriend, her long-term boyfriend,
her only partner, only other partner, right? with your permission
and you shared it with your wife or had it in somewhere where
your wife could see it with her permission.
How did you know that you could trust this other person? Right.
What made you trust this other person? Destiny, could you describe
what made you trust this other person?
Oh, well, that's interesting. Well, can we can we talk about
like why you decided to share a bunch of these things with a
like a 19-year-old that you didn't age verify that you admit
in your own DMs you didn't age verify could have been under 18
that you actually in DMs to people were very concerned that they
were under 18 and how that would be the thing that would majorly
sink you out of this entire drama. Right?
How did you come to trust them that this wouldn't be sent? Right?
Cuz he's arguing about
Correct. Well, the foreseeability thing on just sending a video,
that would be stupid. But what about sending a video to an 18-year-old,
17 or 18year-old or 19year-old who you've never met in real life,
had never had a conversation with,
right? Had never had a like a phone call conversation with. What
What about the foreseeability of sending it to that person who
you have no you haven't even verified their identity? For all
you know, they could be catfishing you.
What's the foreseeability then?
But apparently everybody's like, "Oh, they would have just stopped
asking questions at this time."
I said 17, 18, 19. I've I also went out of my way to highlight
how she was very possibly underage. >> Well, yeah, but
it's different because
>> he himself said to me directly, "Man, I'm really scared
that she might be underage cuz that's the only thing that'll
sink me here. I can sweep the rest of it away. I can sweep the
rest of it away, but if she's under if she's under 18, I can't
sweep that away >> because well, you know, she there was
consent there or whatever. It's like what what is the difference
here? Like even if even if it was non-conentual like isn't like
foreseeability is what we're talking about, right? So that would
mean that sending anything because the the Oh my god. Yeah. Foreseeability
for the foreseeability of sending it to a a child, a person who
you couldn't get to fly out of your place because their parents
wouldn't let them, right? Is that not correct, Destiny? Would
that not have been concerning to you that when you asked her
to meet you in real life, she said, "My parents won't let me
fly to you." Was that concerning to you? Or did you think that
that wasn't a big
>> Her lawyers are so cr um
her lawyers are so cringe.
I feel like they when they they it felt like they thought they
were in a TV show and they're like asking me these questions
like they have like these killer gotchas and they're like the
dumbest gotchas in the world. was like, "Bro,
I don't remember how much of this I talked about, but he's like,
"You testified today that you actually didn't have your law firm
contact Kiwi Farm. So, did you lie earlier when you said that
you did?" And I'm like, "I had my assistant contact them. My
assistant is not my lawyer." And then every time they would get
like shut down in a line of questioning the
Okay, who hears these like little tidbits of testimony is like,
"Oh, Dusty totally crushed it. Dashy it."
judge like picks his papers up and he like shuffles them. I can
tell that he's like aborted a whole lot of questioning.
Ah,
because the judge shuffled papers.
Given that Jane also sent your videos without your consent, do
you not have a good chance of winning even if hypothetically
you sent videos after the party date? Like, does that be even
matter beyond keeping the guest alive? Um, even if the Abby stuff
was true, which it's not, but >> I don't I don't think
has he outright stated she didn't have his consent or something
because I believe that's not true at all. >> Even if it
was, there are still like a bunch of other issues that you would
even have to fight to to get >> Oh, I didn't even listen
to that question. Given that Jane also sent your videos without
your consent, do you not have a good chance of winning even if
hypothetically you sent videos after the party date? Like does
Abby even matter beyond keeping the guest alive? Um, even if
the Abby stuff was true, which it's not, but even if it was,
there are still like a bunch of other issues that you would even
have to fight to to get to
a win, let alone damages. Um, but it's um
I don't I'm trying to think of
>> everybody here, everybody in this chat obviously is
just under a total framing of like Destiny's the complete victim
here. Destiny is the total victim.
>> Actually, I don't even know how that would work. Like
let's say some law was passed in 2024 that said you can't say
you to somebody and let's say somebody says you in 2023 and then
someone like well you could you sue the the second person. I'm
actually I don't know how that works. I'm not sure.
Okay.
The
>> from the profile leaks got you. >> I hope there
is an unclean hands defense on the basis of her sending your
videos. Okay. I don't like that this meme gets passed around
so much because people keep saying this. People keep saying this
thing. It's like, okay, well, Destiny might have done a bad thing,
but she did a bad thing, too. No, that means that nobody did
a bad thing.
No, it doesn't. Like, people say two wrongs don't make a right,
but in some circumstances, they kind of do. For instance, if
one side is being accused of a party and then it turns out, actually,
no, the other side wanted to rape the other person. That doesn't
mean that two people raped each other. That just means they had,
right?
Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on. But that's not the thing here.
Like, what if we just said I I I stole $300 from somebody and
they stole $300 from me. Well, that means no crime was committed.
No,
that does mean two crimes were committed. What are we talking
about?
It's not okay to steal from somebody so long as they stole from
you.
Also, the idea of like a would be like you doing a an act together
in the same
These these weren't acts done together in the same room. Let's
see how DG responds to that totally idiotic
It cancels out. He's right. They kind of do. He's right. So,
like if there's an agreement or discussion before
each >> two wrongs make a right. Mhm. Oh, this guy's I
think they
So like if there's an agreement or discussion beforehand about
like you know who do we send these videos to what is the policy
around this and then there was agreement and then an understanding
at least there right this is this is just sad it's sad to like
not understand >> it doesn't mean like oh I guess both
sides violate agreements oh the agreement was probably not what
this one person who's lied about like 20 different things has
presented it as you >> who lied about 20 different things
did they really they really lie about 20 different things.
Okay. All right. All right.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I wanted to pull something up for
this. Let me find it. Let me find it. Lying about 20 different
things. Let me check it out. I think I have I think I have a
little link for this. Let me start looking through some of his
statements because it's just like crazy how he um how he does
some of these things. I think it's these logs where he talks
about the Pixie thing, right? Is this the logs?
Oh, yeah. I think she gave three different answers. So, he just
talks about this is the pixie thing, right? Okay, hold on. But
let's read from the bottom.
Oh, he talks he basically throws Kylo under the bus, too. I didn't
even see this from before. Oh my goodness,
dude. Gravitas. Kylo is being
in this and she shouldn't have been talking about this at all.
Lol W. So, already throws Kylo under the bus, says she shouldn't
have been talking about it at all. Um, we'll see. Maybe we'll
check the Kylo video after this. It's just hard explaining to
non-gooners what the Goonar lifestyle is.
Uh-huh. The Gooner lifestyle.
So, listen. I want you to imagine that you have like a a label
that gets applied to you, right? Like consent violator. Okay?
What's the best way to deal with a label like consent violator?
It's to rebrand, right? Oh, I don't like that word. Consent violator.
What? No. No. I'm not a consent violator. I have a gooner lifestyle,
guys. I don't I don't just like habitually violate consent. I
have a gooner lifestyle.
Uh-huh. This is as transparent to everybody who has any amount
of free will or or intelligence or co uh or cognition. Okay?
Everybody understands that this is the exact same as rebranding
to maps. Okay?
We're not going to let that happen. You are not going to remap.
You're not going to rebrand the map. In this case, you cannot
take your habitual consent violations and rebrand to a gooner
lifestyle.
Yourself, okay?
You can't do it. You are a consent violator. That is not that
has nothing to do with being a gooner. Okay? And he's so lucky
that a lot of these other things probably can't really be used
by the jury against him. Right? The fact that he violated Molina's
consent, the fact that he violated Saj's consent, the fact that
he violated Aby's consent, the fact that he violated Cher's consent,
the fact that he's violated these people's consent. Okay, there
are more, but I can't I'm just off the top of my head, I'm not
ringing them all out, but those can't be used to prove that he
did this crime. But to call it a good lifestyle when so many
people have come out and said you shared these things non-consensually,
like nobody's confused. Nobody who's paying attention or isn't
just a part of your weird your weirdo freak community, okay?
Everyone else understands what's going on. We all see it.
You can't You can't get away from the consent violations. We
all see what you are, right? He's sully in Gunnar's good name.
Well, he's just making it seem like, "Oh, guys, I was just like,
off, guys. They caught me. They caught me. I was just being inappropriately."
No, you're violating people's consent repeatedly over and over
and over again
after being asked not to. Nicely.
God, where is the Bob? I always have this Bob 7 clip. Dude, he
was literally asked not to. Hey, don't do that. Here, one second.
Let's just play. I'll be right >> So,
a long time ago.
Okay. So, a long time ago. So, sometimes, so obviously, okay,
me and Lena send nudes to people. Um, me and had a conversation
about there were a few girls we talked to. I was like, "Oh, cool.
Like, we should record videos of like us going to send to people.
Like, it's fun." So, we do this. Um, I kind of like have like
my little archive of like material that I'll send to people if
I want to. Um, there were girls that I talked to um past that
that I'd send stuff of like either me or me and Molina. and Molina
talked to me and she was like, "Hey, um if you're going to send
any videos to um new girls that we haven't talked about, like
let me know that first." Um because she wanted to be careful.
And I was like, "Okay, sure." That was fine. I didn't think of
it at the time cuz I didn't think it mattered, but um yeah, sure.
So, I thought about that. So, that was like an issue that me
and Molina had that we talked about and then we resolved, right?
the way that the way
>> Okay, so this isn't even the first time he's had this
exact thing spelled out for him directly.
Directly.
This is why every single [__] who says, "Guys, he's
not going to do it again. He got caught. He knows it's bad. It's
been explained to him. Now he's like he's been penalizing. He's
never going to do it again.
This is already like the third or fourth time it's been it's
happened. This is the third or fourth time he's had to have this
lesson taught to him. Why? Why the would you think he'd learn
his
By the way, he said Bob 7 screen sharing nudes, right? It's like
career ending
Life ending allegations.
Jury will love this clip too, dude. And one of the people who
said he was sharing things non-conensually this time is the person
whose consent he violated here,
right? He literally tried to make the Gooner culture, the Goonar
culture argument back here during the Bob 7 arc. This should
have been the only time this was applicable. Okay. You cannot
forgive this a second time. All right.
You can't.
Lauren Southern is the only woman he protected. Uh tried to.
Yeah.
Her son on the other hand,
that kid's identity is just up for grabs thanks to
Okay. All right. We continue on with whatever this is. Eventually,
he gets onto some skitso mind map, so that'll be fun. Okay. He
does he does state of play for the completely mentally
Check desks. I don't want to check your DMs, Radiant, because
I hate you. You're
I actually hired um Cyber is now doing my new stuff. And Radiant
is fired. I have 450 Hassan posts ready to go, boy.
Yeah, boy. Yeah, boy.
What would you do if they drop the case, but the hearing stays
sealed? It seems like the hearing being sealed would mean a good
amount of reputation. No, that can't possibly be they can't do
that. No
I don't think they're dropping the case. I don't see why they
would drop the >> I think that here's what
>> Dude, that transcript I don't think that transcript
means anywhere near as much as he thinks it does. I have no I
have no way to know for sure, but he's like hinging everything
on this transcript for a procedural hearing for a motion to grant
a preliminary injunction to get him to stop leaking more pixie
sex and for a couple other things that they should never have
asked for, right? Like it's not really actually material to the
case. It's like saying he's an it's like a it's a hearing on
why he's an he thinks it's going to be like super material to
the case. If they if that happened, then what I would do is I
would go to the deep jungles of Brazil and I would take Iawaska
and I would convene with the gods. And while convening with the
gods, I would sit >> with pen and parchment and I would
try my best to recall every single word that was said. Exactly.
You literally bought and received the transcript and told all
of us about it. You literally said in DGlo logs, you bought and
received the full transcript. What is the purpose of this?
I don't I don't even know what the purpose of this would be.
You literally told everybody you bought and received the transcript
already. It was just the seal that's preventing you from releasing
it >> during that hearing. And then I would read my recollection
on stream. That's what I would do. Okay.
You literally have the full transcript. You told us about it.
Is there anything in motion right now for counter suing dope
or Abby? No. Although I don't know. He's more or less said what's
in the transcript. No, he talks about it constantly.
>> Oh, is there any recourse for sewing suing Doe or Abby?
So, Abby or um or
I don't I don't know what the validity
any case there would even be or what that the problem is that
like my like the problem is that I have a real law firm that
likes to win cases. So if I just want to do some dexious litigation,
I'm like can we just
Oh, hold on, hold on, hold on. I actually missed I forgot we
were going over this and then I hit play on the video to be right
back. We kept going. I went I went way past this guys. Also,
he said Pixie lied 20 times and I forgot to go through the rest
of this. Whoops. There's a lot of other good stuff in here cuz
he continues to comment on the Kyla with the Turkey Tom interview.
I think Kyla asked me something like, "Did you explicitly ask
her if you could send this video to some girl?" And I said, "No,
it didn't really work that way." That's not what Kyla What did
Kyla say about it? Do we have the Hold on. Turkey Tom
not so aerodite.
Hold on. We We'll just see. >> Leaked them to Sunday. I
think Becket,
>> it's somewhere right around here. >> What do you
think about this? This is what Kyla was suggesting. And Aaron
was saying like, I think she's being sneaky. And Pixie was being
like, I don't think she was being she's being sneaky. Um, like
early December when I went, "Did she know you're recording and
did she consent to it?" Um he said that she did know about the
recording. Like she's aware she did consented to the actual filming
of it, >> but that he said specifically
probably not. Um like it was 3 years ago. I don't remember specifically
and like things were open like this, but yeah, probably not.
I didn't get like explicit consent. And I said, Stephen, that's
really [__] up. Like that's not okay. Um, and so
just to be clear, he'd probably
he would say, "I didn't >> bad Stephen. Bad bad dog." No.
No.
No. Do that was bad.
Now I'm going to love you forever and never bring this up in
your in your presence ever again. Okay. But bad
bad
Okay. So, did you explicitly ask her if you could send it to
the video to some girl? I said, "No, it didn't really work that
way." So, it was an explicit consent to send the video. I don't
know about to some girl, but send the video, I guess. Didn't
really work that way. I don't remember for sure, but no, probably
not was what he said. Okay.
This was a Never mind. But like during the the hearing, Pixie
told the judge that she sent all of our videos to her ex-boyfriend,
and I didn't even know that. lol W. Then why did she when when
basically Pixie asks like, "Oh, who could possibly know about
us having sex?" Pixie is the one who says, "Obviously my boyfriend
would know, right? That was the whole arrangement that I got
permission to you." Like that's that's the whole thing.
Anyway, but that was kind of what she what we said when we recorded
stuff. Just don't leak it. Lol. Basically,
So, like only with your like exact stable partner right now.
Don't let it like don't send it to people. Maybe if you want
to show them on your phone or something.
Okay. Like no girl has ever damned me in my life and asked if
they could share any specific video we've recorded with anyone
else else ever because that's just not usually how it works.
But some girl aka your wife has told you, "Hey, you're sharing
that without my consent. That's that's up. Don't do that."
So why why is this even relevant? The exact situation we're seeing
here has been pointed out to you as a up thing and you agreed
you had to stop it, that it was wrong of you to do that,
right? Hey, I can't just send two new people without asking that
person, without getting their consent.
Why is he pretending that this exact this exact misunderstanding
hasn't been cleared up for him in the past?
Yes, Molina did this with pre Molina literally got mad at him
for not doing it with pre-approved for doing it with other girls
after the ones she had
And then Molina had to find out when these leaks came out that
actually he just kept doing it anyway. He just kept sharing this
stuff to randoms.
Oh boy. Like okay. Uh Lin Woo. I mean I wouldn't call them virgins.
There's probably somebody going, "Destiny, aren't these people
just virgins who don't know how like sharing videos works? Aren't
they just virgins?
Aren't they just virgins? Destiny Lyn Woo. I mean, I wouldn't
call them virgins. It's probably not normal, per se. It's just
to Listen, it was a Goonar culture. Okay, I'm trying to do this
remapping of habitual consent violator, somebody with no respect
for I'm trying to remap that onto Gooner culture, okay? Could
you please respect me?
Could you please respect me and my gooner culture where I just
share people's nudes or videos without ever asking if that's
okay or ever getting any form of consent at all?
Okay. Um,
it's just annoying when I get a huge spotlight of me and then
people think I'm engaged in some exceptionally egregious behavior
or something. You are engaged in exceptionally egregious
People People literally got mad at just the Pixie DMs. You are
engaged in actual egregious behavior.
God cha. No clue. She's being insane stupid manipulatable. It's
hard to say. This is about Pixie, right? And there's some picture
here. Do I want to go find that picture really quickly? Give
me a second.
Let me go find the picture here real quick.
I look like that. Okay, here we go. Not that one.
Uh, this one.
This one, I think. No longer available. I can't even look at
it, dude. Hold on. Let me Let me see if this will work in Discord.
Sometimes this works. Oh, this did work. Okay.
So, this is the this is the picture.
Happy birthday to the best girl I know at Pixie Love on your
actual birthday. Pixie love at Lauren de Lagona.
Happy birthday, Pixie.
To which he says, like, it's so blatant.
Like it's so blatant.
What? Dude, the idea the fact that he doesn't understand what
like friendship is and doesn't understand like human companionship
at all and like every every instance of people just being friends
in a like platonic I don't need to get something from you way
is just blatant evidence of a conspiracy against him. Like he
he actually it's he is the robot in Westworld. He has no idea
of what this is, but it makes him
He can't fathom it. He actually can't fathom it.
H Victor C26. I think she gave three different answers in our
hearing about what the agreement was. Jesse, I think she said
once we agreed like don't send it around. And then I think she
said I thought we he could send it to his wife. And then I think
she said I didn't tell him he could send it to anyone. We agreed
like don't send it around. I didn't tell him. >> Where
is Oh, hold on. Bacto, thank you for the 15 months.
>> Where do any of these things contradict? Is there a
contradiction in any of those three statements?
Can somebody point out the contradiction in these three statements
to me?
I thought he could send it to his wife. I didn't tell him he
could send it to anyone. Those don't contradict. I thought he
could send it to his wife.
What uh what is this link that you've just sent me? Hold on.
What it is? What it is?
Oh, this one doesn't work either. This content is no longer available.
Hold on. I have to put this in like a Discord chat to open it.
Oh, wait. He posted
No way. No way. He posted it again, but these are the logs this
time. Okay, hold on.
Hold on. Where did I just I just opened these. [__]
Hold on. Right here.
I like that they even smile the same now. Holy L W. And it's
the same picture. It's the same picture.
It's the same picture. I can't believe they even smile the same
now.
Dude, this guy's having like an actual schizophrenic meltdown.
It's so funny.
I like that they even have the same smile now. Holy.
I think this smile is This is the smile of a Kiwi farmer right
here, guys. Lauren and K Lauren and Pixie, they're Kiwi farmers
now. This is the smile of a Kiwi farmer.
What does that even mean? Nobody knows what it means, but it's
provocative. Okay, nobody gets it.
Dude, how does this guy get off on judging other people's mental
health in any way when these are the kinds of things he's saying?
It's actually insane.
When he says he has offline friends, do you actually believe
him? Well, he might just be hearing voices at this point. Like,
it's a there's a decent chance he's just hearing voices in his
head.
I think,
dude,
h it's just it's wild. It's wild. And I stopped following it.
I stopped following it for a little while because I was going
to like I was just moving away from it, right?
And he just keeps wanting to drag me back in. He just wants to
keep talking about me or my Discord. I want to move away from
it. I want to go into drama stuff. I want to talk about TAP and
TAP getting hacked. And this guy can't stop talking about
I think Destiny's actually mentally broken because of what happened.
It seems that way.
Got to wonder what kind of dude takes videos of himself sucking
off strangers. That is a excellent question.
Do you have the text of Pixie? I don't know if there are texts
like that,
I do think Destiny, one of the first things he said was, "Well,
obviously we could have shared it shared it with somebody cuz
I said obviously, you know, my wife has access to stuff. She
She'll probably see something, right?
Oh, a gay dude. Dude, that was funny. That was like um That was
Ardite and Nick. That was their response to like the secret pocket
recordings. That was their response was I think that's just a
part of gay culture, guys. You just like secretly record [__]
[__] because that's a part of gay culture. Your grinder
hookups, you can totally you can totally record those, you know,
without consent because that is just gay culture.
Of
course he's mindbroken. He aggressively platformed you hoping
that you wouldn't become Basheran.
dude.
God. Where? I knew this was going to take forever to get through.
I tried watching this. I was trying to pre-screen a little bit
of this before the stream and I was like, "Dude, I have to pause
every 30 seconds. I have to pause every 5 seconds because he
just says so many things." And then I have to go back and play
it again so you guys can get all the connecting context.
Anyway,
anyway, anyway, anyway,
we're back to the video.
I'll pull it back about 20 seconds so we can see where we are.
I'm getting water for Abby. No, although I don't know if
I don't I don't know what the validity of any case there would
even be or what that the problem is that like my like the problem
is that I have a real law firm that likes to win cases. So if
I just want to do some dexious litigation, I'm like can we just
see these the uh hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on we're
about to get there. Okay, let me open up the uh under your skin
album. We need the under under your skin under your skin album.
Is it under your skin? Is that what it's called? Oh, that's not
what it's called. What is it? Oh, what are these songs from?
Kiss. Oh, [__] What is the What is the skitso? Under
the skin. Under the skin. Yes, under the skin. Cuz we're about
to enter the actual skitso zone. Okay. We're about to get there.
Uh soundtrack.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
think they would go for it just for the memes, right? That's
like more memey.
>> He's about to open up paint.
>> Doesn't the judge need to order it dismissed? They can't
decide that on their own. No, you can dismiss your own cases.
For instance, when Tim P claimed that he was going to sue Kla
Harris and Joe Biden for
misquing a clip of his on Twitter, uh, because he wanted all
the clout of saying he sued them for 600 bucks, he withdrew that
case
I don't know why you Yeah, I don't know why you call that dismissing
your own
Withdrawing, better word.
>> Have you seen the South Mar? I haven't seen the episode.
Um, but Pull up. Pull up paint. It's right here. It's got to
be right here against Lauren. Um, I mean, how I mean, she's the
>> How? She's been leading a conspiracy against you. What
do you mean how? Shouldn't it be easy to prove that? Don't you
have proof of that? To make that claim? She's literally leading
a conspiracy against you purely maliciously to harm your reputation
and harm you personally because you rejected her and you have
evidence of this. Why wouldn't you sue her?
There's a whole conversation that needs to be had. Um,
>> I don't know. >> A wobble combinator thing for
the 10 months. Let's go.
>> There's like this is like a whole thing. Me and D should
have just talked about this on anything else. We talked about
this off stream. >> God, hold on. >> Um, I've talked
about this on stream a >> I actually have to pause cuz
I'm getting a drink. Second,
like actually getting a pop cuz I am going to enjoy this. Okay,
I'm getting a pop. Got a Pepsi Zero Sugar here. Okay, Pepsi Zero
Sugar.
My drink of choice to really enjoy things. Okay, I realize I'm
like white trash. All right, I know. I know. I know.
I know.
We're just having a couple pops out here. Okay. Unsubbed.
This is like Canadian culture. All right. Just having a couple
pops
with the boys. Having a couple pops. All right. All right.
>> Let's go. Skitso mind map time. >> Love to see
it. places like Kiwi Farms or um like I don't even want to say
snark subsidies cuz they didn't exist back then. Um L cow or
PL or these aren't the only ones I've ever heard.
>> Cherry I'm not making it up. Yes, Cherry saw the supermarket
signs. They say they like people are going to anti and people
are going to hate and people are going to be weird and you know
it's fine. Like you have I mean one you have a right to do that.
>> Is it fine? Seems like it's not fine at all. You know,
if you want to talk [__]
>> Uh, are you concerned Destiny would be doing a Dan and
registering his streams into the Library of Congress?
No. I I'm not an American citizen. I don't even know if copyright
law has any jurisdiction over me. Right. I don't have any American
incorporation. I don't know why American copyright law would
have any effect on me. You'd have to sue me in Canada. >> Yeah,
that's fine. I don't think that's
a problem.
>> Yes, they do. I think they have to sue me under Canadian
law. You can sue me, but you have to sue me under Canadian law.
You shouldn't be able to sue me in an American court. If I have
no American incorporation, I'm not American citizen.
>> I mean, obviously, as a public figure, I don't want
anybody to be mean to me ever. But, you know, you don't have
a right to have nobody be mean about you. The the thing that's
happened recently, and it's so weird because I'm trying to think
of this has only happened on the left. I'm trying to think if
this has happened on the right. I I feel like it must have. I'm
just not as aware of it. But the thing that's happened that is
so toxic has been the weaponization of these. Like it's so funny,
dude. He's about to he's about to describe weaponized like harassment
and he talked about this with Dan on anything else. Can you guys
think of someone who's like weaponized harassment who's close
to
Why?
What?
like sub forums
and
just the the basically I would call it the open kind of um
collaboration with them.
The open collaboration
this is not good. Um
this is not good. So what is the open collaboration? Collaboration
would be to me planning, right? If you're going to say that we're
all public content creators creating public content, collaboration
can't possibly be somebody finding a link over here like a chatter
finding a link from one of these and going somewhere else and
going, "Hey, you should check this out." That can't be what collaboration
is, right? Just somebody saying like, "Here's a here's a clip
from Destiny's stream. You should watch it." That can't be. There
has to be a higher bar for collaboration than, "Oh, you saw a
link or you saw a clip that's somewhere and you put it somewhere
else."
This is why like my policy, by the way, on all on all of these
people. Now, I I do not accept doxing or anything on any of my
platforms that I >> So, I don't know why he's already totally
avowed doxing on every single platform. I don't know why he's
pretending he hasn't. He's avowed the doxing of me, of Queen,
of whoever you can get to, right? He's avowed this on all of
his platforms. I have a feeling that somebody probably told him,
"Hey, you should uh you should not do that. That's probably not
smart where it's against the terms of service." Um, and that's
it. I don't give a [__] about any of this otherwise
because these >> He's saying only when it's against the
terms of service. Just to be clear, he has no principled stance
against doxing. He did. He said it was the most one of the most
disgusting things you could do, right? Months ago. Uh he absolutely
had a problem with doxing, but apparently not anymore. It's just
oh only if it's against the toos. So in his chat or on Twitter,
he's like totally fine to try to dox people. That's what he wants
to do. Will he going to be surely Willie will stop posting in
the Daliban subreddit, right? Surely, surely,
I'm not even the only person from my community he's like tried
to dox or amplify the doxes of, right? I find it particularly
egregious that he would intentionally amplify the docs of Hutch
repeatedly and never let Hutch know that it was out there, right?
That seems pretty crazy to me. >> People are crazy. Um,
that's the only
>> Does it count when you say it to Willie Mack and then
he posts it on to YouTube? I think there's an argument for Destiny
where he has used the the constellation of his platforms, his
platforms as an
to dox and make death threats. And that if you look at him rather
than each of these individual platforms, it seems insane to me
that a platform would go, you know what, we're not going to take
into account anything else here. Right? That seems crazy to me.
He's he's absolutely weaponizing all of his platforms to continue
to make these threats and continue to try and harass people into
not talking about him anymore. He is at this point he is just
Keels except Keles like uh with a way bigger audience and way
more money, right? Like trying to fight against Kiwi Farms and
all these other places
by by emulating Kiwi Farms, by the way. Trying to fight against
Kiwi Farms by emulating Kiwi Farms.
Destiny was always okay with doxing. He was always okay with
doxing in like certain situations. I think um I think broadly
like other content creators who hadn't doxed you, he would he
wouldn't do that in the past. >> Only reason why I don't
do it because the idea that um
so like like if you want to like I'm an extreme example obviously,
but like if if you read my KB is actually hilarious. These people
are like actively involved in stages of litigation where they
try to get like leaks or >> actively involved in stages
of litigation where they try to get leaks.
Is he he's talking about his Kiwi Farms thread or is he talking
about Rakita's Kiwi Farms thread? Cuz like Rakita, they're like
trying to get all kinds of things on Rakita. I don't know what
he's talking about in his thread. >> Pass stuff on to lawyers
or they're like trying to push certain narratives. Three days
ago. >> Yeah, that's what Kiwi Farms is. They they push
narratives. They don't like you and they push narratives. >> So,
I think in one page of my thread, five different people who are
close to me got doxed for not being hard enough against me. Like,
>> I don't know if that's true, but if it were, that sucks.
Doxing sucks. >> Five different people in the span of 24
hours. Um, and it's like very we totally like we totally disavow
that. We do not want doxers around us. We don't want people doxed.
I totally disavow that. I've always disavowed that. So I banned
anybody who's bringing up the willy from before. Right. >> He's
late, too. Like they don't like try to hide it. They're just
like >> are the Oh, but yes. Sorry. Five people close to
him. Five people close to him.
>> Oh, like um I saw like Hutch. >> Oh, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Five people close to him >> said this thing.
>> Does anybody have his docs? Does anybody dox him before?
It'll be like super blatant. And it also sucks cuz it's hard
to even talk about it cuz even just by saying that in a way I've
kind of sort of like now passed along his docs, you >> Sure.
It's hard to talk about it. The up thing here is what he's going
to allege is that like I'm connected to Kiwi Farms. Bro, Kiwi
Farms has had never never would have cared about me ever if I
wasn't associated with Destiny, right?
But I don't like there's no coordination. They watch my stream
because Destiny is unhinged about me. They watch my stream and
also a bunch of the people who are docked were docked before
I was even a streamer or docked before I had ever like uh known
about Destiny's like obvious consent violations. He like he tries
to pile up all of these things as if they're like all related
or all connected. They're really not.
Here, we'll just we'll go through this >> Who are three
days ago, I think in one page of my thread, five different people
who are close to me got doxed for not being hard enough against
me. Like five different people in the span of 24 hours.
That sounds really bad.
Five different people close to him got doxed.
That sucks. Now, Destiny, keeping up on Kiwi Farms and being
somebody who's very concerned about those people, obviously would
have gone ahead and like helped those people out, right? He would
have done something to make sure that those people were not going
to like that they were informed and not scared and like, "Hey,
this is not a big deal, right?" Obviously.
Uh, Destiny, send it to them so they can see what's going on,
what they what they are doing. Send it to who? Josiah and Hutch
and stuff.
Oh, me. They can figure it out themselves.
I thought these were people close to you, Destiny. I thought
these were people close to you that you're implying like you
care about and you're very, very offended on their behalf.
Nah, they can figure it out themselves.
Are you serious?
Are you Are you kidding me? He does this all the time, by the
way. He'll he'll go and he'll virtue signal about I can't believe
they put Molina in this lawsuit because it violated her privacy
like that. I can't believe they put Cherry in this lawsuit. You
violated their privacy like that. It's like you don't give a
about their privacy. You've violated their consent. You violated
their privacy repeatedly. Why are you virtue signaling about
this degenerate?
And here again, he's like now on stream the next day virtue signaling
about this. But when he was said, somebody says, "Hey, would
you send this stuff along to them?" He goes, "No, they can figure
it out themselves."
Very sad. Very embarrassing. total piece of total degenerate.
Okay,
he blocked all of them on Twitter. He doesn't seem close to them.
But when he's virtue signaling to his audience, he'll say, "Oh,
it's five people close to me." And he seems very concerned. He's
like, "This is unacceptable. That's why I'm doxing people. I
didn't dox these people. I don't I don't like doxing. I hate
doxing." But he's like trying to come after me, trying to dox
me. Bailed, by the way, but trying to dox me.
And I don't have anything to do with this. But he doesn't even
care about these people. He just wants a way to attack me for
criticizing him, right? That's all he's wanted the whole time.
He doesn't care about them. The care the performative caring
about them, the performative idea that he cares about them is
is totally fake. Does not give a
just doesn't give a. And it's so transparent. And you know, you'd
think Very Violet would see this and go, "Oh man, maybe this
guy isn't such a good person." But no, he's totally he's totally
swallowed all of the jizz. He's like he's in
Sorry. I try to I try to use the [__] vampire thing
and uh I think of it like blood and now it's like g it's too
gross. I sound like destiny. I can't do that analogy.
But he's um he's
he's on Twitter defending Destiny still. He's like all over the
place defending Destiny.
Like it's crazy.
Why wouldn't this like give you a good idea that this person's
like kind of
right? That he's pretending like this doxing is such a huge deal
to him and then when you're like, "Hey, we should reach out.
Those guys are your former friends. We should reach out." Nah,
they can figure it out themselves.
Okay. I I guess so.
I guess so.
Um and it's like very blatant, too. Like they don't like try
to hide it. They'll be like, "Oh, like um I saw like Hutch said
this thing on this. Does anybody have his docs? Does anybody
dox him before?" it'll be like super blatant and it also sucks
cuz it's hard to even talk about it cuz even just by saying that
in a way I've kind of sort of like now passed along his docs,
you know, but the fact that like Kiwi Farms exists to do that
>> very concerning when he went to his chat and literally
put the links to the pages in his chat. >> You have all
these kind of like snark subreddits um or like places like um
like Discord servers. We'll say like just Discord server. Um
>> apparently again this is like a a snark discord server.
I think he also Yeah, dude.
>> where they kind of like engage in this behavior. The
fact that this goes to unhinged people online like bad empanada
and then I'm using the Hassan model here to do this and then
all of this stuff gets repeated uncritically by people like Casey
Tron and Denims and then he hasn't even said dude information
comes bad stuff comes out from these things. It's like is it
doxing? There's no doxing. Doxing is not allowed in my in my
no creator has been doxed through my never never happened. >> Um
or like places like um like Discord servers will say like just
to go >> and in the future if that were to ever happen
the person who did it would be permanent from every single platform
I have automatically >> discord server um where they kind
of like engage in this behavior. The fact that this goes to unhinged
people online like bad >> they engage in this behavior.
So engaging in snark-l like behavior. We don't have to describe
the behavior cuz we're just going to web that together, right?
We don't have to we don't have to describe it. We just say snark
jtock snark jtock snark. Keep in mind when he pulls up the logs
of people making fun of him, it's people calling him fat, right?
People calling him fat and then people like laughing about uh
what how he like can barely hold on to a cat or something. It's
like the it's like the lightest ribbing.
It's like nothing. It's like nothing.
Every time he looks at logs, it is
Like the said about me in his chat is far worse.
Far worse. >> Empanada. And then I'm using the Hassan model
here to do this. And then all of this stuff. >> Okay. So
it so stuff from from Jtock or Snark goes to bad empanada. >> It's
repeated uncritically by people like Casey Tron and Frogan and
Denims. And then Hassan will directly like give credence or sometimes
even him like you don't have to take my word for it. Hassan already
spoke in the past. Where where does he give credence to like
totally unfounded things? Do you guys remember? This is what
I'm talking about. This is why like this is why like this happened.
We'll get to like the genesis of this. By the way, did did this
bad empanada Hassan connection exist before a certain campaign
against a certain streaming website existed?
Did this did this whatever this thing is up here? Did any of
this exist before somebody escalated it to that point or I forget.
Destiny, it's almost like somebody used your community to escalate
things to this point. No.
H. But regardless, do you guys remember? So, he's saying, "Oh,
Hassan will sometimes repeat these things uncritically, too."
Do you remember what happened when the CPS and the the stuff
came out? Do you remember what Hassan said? No, guys. That's
stupid. He didn't retweet anything on it and he said, "That's
stupid. Ethan's a good dad. Shut the up. Stop being weirdos."
Right? That's what he said. So this idea that even Hassan's just
taking everything bad empanata says and like repeating it uncritically
that's
asked about like never hosting people like bad empanada.
Um
this model is impossible to
well it's not impossible to fight against but it's it's a I shouldn't
say that way it's just a different it's just a different weaponization
of like doxing and harassment that didn't exist in the past.
Um,
I didn't say Hassan doesn't spread rumors. I'm saying he doesn't
do it totally uncritically or with like total malice, right?
That's that's the way he's painting it. I'm saying Hassan would
have been super Ethan there, but he went, "No, no, no. Here's
the line. I'm not I'm not doing that. That
>> it's Yeah, I don't know how to I don't know what the
son told Adam Freeland Destiny debates his wife." Destiny 100%
debated his wife. What are you talking about?
That was like literally one of Molina's primary complaints was
I can't even I can't even have like concerns because I'll get
debated out of my concerns. What are we talking about? Solution
is or the counter >> I think Dinglingus is is uh messing
>> This is um is this why Aspen subreddit has gone so conservative?
I don't I don't I don't see conservative groups do this, but
maybe they do do this. Um and I just don't see it because I'm
not in those spaces. I'm not sure.
Hold on. Destinity.
network doxing. We I my stream has no relation to doxing. My
my stream, my discord, no relation to doxing anyone around Destiny
at all. I think the worst thing that's happened is we've had
some people who get in romantic relationships or they're really
good and they get in fights and they will like dox each other
like chatters. And it's like, okay, those people got to go. Those
people have to be separated. That's really weird, right? But
like that's not a culture in this. It's like literally a hard
rule against it. So I don't know what we're I don't know what
we're
vertical integration like
um the GOP. True. Yeah. >> Are you talking about the map?
I'm talking about like he has me connected here and he's like
this is somebody said decentralized or the the like vertical
integration of doxing and it's like dude I don't I literally
don't do I don't participate in doxing. Don't believe in
Oh, but it's funny because um
somebody typed this message yesterday. It was so true and I never
thought about it this way before. Apparently, oh look, we have
a schizo theory from somebody
Guys, guys, I'm going to say some insane coming up, okay? But
understand that I'm just reading someone else's message, so it's
fine.
Uh JTO's connected to bad and Panata apparently. We'll get to
why that happened in just a little bit, I think.
Um, oh, there's so there's another place where this also happens
that's comparable to justical um and like snark subreddits and
I would call it it's like in between Kiwi Farms and Snark subreddits.
It's called um spicy chat. Um.
Oh,
it's sp guys. Guys, it's spicy chat. It's Uhoh.
Oh, we forgot. Dude, he's just going to get all of his enemies
on this chart. All right. I would be shocked by the end by the
end of all of this by the end of all of these lawsuits, we'll
have like Molina will be at the top like having directed all
of this against him or something. Okay. He'll got he'll have
every single person who's ever said something bad about him on
this chart.
chart. Yeah, the the map. >> This is um Chub Logic's like
degenerate. >> mean the web >> place basically like
a crazy chat in his Discord where people do like a bunch of this
like doxing and spreading of information and everything, right?
>> So apparently Chud Logic, our our good friend of the
stream, Chud Logic, is allowing a bunch of doxing and degenerate
to happen in spicy chat. Very sad. You hate to see it. Um, >> surely
we're going to see any substantiation of this at all. He's not
just going to make things up, right? Surely, surely we'll see
some substantiation, something. There's got to be something.
Somebody said to me, there's a couple more interesting things
about the spicy chat commentary sphere. I've realized one, um,
they have an OP strategy of dis
that's a good point, Mark Cardi. Hold on. I forgot. Dan was a
open and w like happy participant in spicy chat for months.
Did he not did he not point any of this doxing out to Destiny
that happens?
Dan sat in spicy chat all the time. He went he came into spicy
chat. He took pictures of his cars. Hey guys, look at I'm I'm
repairing my car. Guys, look. I'm repairing my car. Isn't this
cool? Why is he so friendly with all of these doctors?
I believe Dan just left spicy chat recently. where someone in
their audience will do something crazy and the creator will say
I really disavow this in a sarcastic tone but a laugh at it and
say that's so funny but I disavow but that was cool lol it creates
there's that second part doesn't happen it's I totally disavow
that it's a it's a joke when it's like something funny and unhinged
gets said I totally disavow that that's crazy do not do that
right
but that's a chat meme that's not like a that's not like a spicy
chat meme that's just like a that's a streamer chat meme
And by the way, like lots of the things you disavow, you'll say,
"No, no, no, no." Like that can't be allowed in my community,
right? I would never allow that in my community. >> This
environment where the audience has signal that any crazy behavior
is acceptable because it created plausible
>> Yeah. No, Dan is still in the >> Discord against
the bad thing. They've been doing this with that empanada a lot
recently where he's become like funny and cool in this community.
Yeah. The funny things bad empanada does are like going into
a video game and somebody he says is like an IDF secretary mimicking
Ela Klein. That's funny and I disavow it, but it is funny. When
bad empanada doxes people, there's no hah, that's so funny, but
I disavow but it's kind of funny. No, it's I totally disavow
that. You shouldn't do that. That's gross, right? There's no
there's no equivocate. There's nothing happening there that gives
any indication that we're okay with it.
I even go out of my way when badit happens to people I hate like
Willie Mack, I'll go out of my way to say that's gross. That's
disgusting. That that's stupid. like that. That can't be a thing.
You can't get mad at this guy for his internet commentary and
put his wife at risk. That's sick. Don't do that. Right. That's
my approach.
But it doesn't matter here. I'm getting webbed into apparently
people who do this. I don't even know who would do this about
actual doxing. I don't think so. Using spicy chat for separation
too. Um using spicy chat for separation for the >> separation
from what behavior. Uh just etc. talk like 10 times more there
than even their own community. And all of the biggest Kiwi Farmes
psychos are there as well. So apparently we talk there more than
our own communities, which is obvious. How much does Destiny
talk in his Discord?
Is there a reason you think that like people would talk somewhere
else where they're not like the guy who the community is built
around? Do you guys think that might happen for like a
It's because obviously like people want to ask you questions.
They want to ask you about content. They want to ask you about
what you said on stream. Sometimes it's nice to go somewhere
where you just like chill and say hi to people and
yeah, it's fine, right? But also, there's the biggest Kiwi Farm
skits there apparently.
Dude, it's like here's a funny tweet. Here's a funny tweet. What
do you guys think? Here's Look at this funny thing that I'm laughing
about. I don't Bro, again, I feel like it's bordering it's bordering.
It's not quite there on like these people's inability to detect
like friendship like uh like hey here's a funny thing I saw for
example uh they were recently posting pics of
I mean I guess I'll say it it's sad but like of like um Willie
is getting married and they've been like posting pictures of
his wife and um and then joing
pictures of Willy's wife in spicy chat about how he got honeypotted
by the IDF.
Um and >> I made that joke. Sorry. That's a funny joke.
Okay, that's a funny joke. I don't begrudge people who make fat
jokes about me because they think that docs photos of me. Okay,
I don't begrudge those people. It's fine. Unfortunately for Willy's
wife, I think is or something and was literally in the IDF or
something and it's just a funny joke. I'm sorry. It's a funny
joke. I don't even know if I made that joke about Willie. I think
I made that joke about
Can we Can we check and make sure there's no IDF baddies in Nicholas's
life right now? Okay, we can't lose another one. >> Then
three. Then Queen and Agistical can forever act above it. But
a large core of their fan base exists in and around spicy chat.
They can indefinitely call doxing bad and pretend that Willie
is crazy while ostensibly the core of their
What do you mean call Willie crazy?
Dude. Dude, the tweet. So my tweet, my retweet of dickers is
a freeze frame of a quote tweet. Like there's a video in the
quote tweet that could be a clip that is somebody else. I think
Queen or somebody else literally
looking at Destiny's quote tweet of that, right? It's Destiny's
quote tweet. All of it at Bedrock is Destiny's quote tweet of
the Gatumodor person, right? That's what everybody's commenting
on. That's how everybody saw it. That is how everyone saw it.
That's what blew it up. Cuz Destiny's willing to amplify anybody's
docs to make other people look to make people he doesn't like
look bad, right? He doesn't care if amplifying that docs hurts
those people. He will amplify that docs to make and anybody criticizing
him look bad. That's what he wants more than anything in the
world.
That's transparent, right? It's obvious.
That's why he did it with Hutch's Docks just recently. That's
why he'll keep doing it with Hutch's Docks. That's why he did
it with Willy's Docks. He wants everybody against him to look
bad. That's his only goal.
It was Queen. I'm saying it's Queman. Yeah. Yeah. It's Queman
reviewing a clip and he doesn't even have the sound on. He's
just talking about it, right?
But it has like some dox in there.
God, doxing is so bad. But you guys should dox all these people
off my platform because it's toos. No, he doesn't even say off
my if you use DG chat. Apparently that's fine with him. That's
where he does his doxing.
Um, Obsidian. No, no, no. He's not doxing Hutch. He Well, I guess
it depends on how you put it. He decided that Hutch apparently
was doxed on KF and he was going to go into his chat and start
posting those links right to Hutch to where Hutch was doxed and
then I think Riyle made a tweet with those logs which by the
way I don't know why that happened. It was a little weird for
me to find out that like Destiny had at the same time finding
out Destiny had apparently like tried to dox me again with a
different person. All right, that I found out that Riyle was
like re was like amplifying that and then Destiny was quote tweeting
him. I don't even know what the [__] going on, right?
Nobody was posting Lily's wife and spicy so far as I've seen.
Yeah, I wouldn't think that was happening. Most most people like
the spicy mods understand that there are unhinged like DJs and
that would want to report them, right? Like most of those people
realize that so they keep it pretty clean in there.
Anyway, so Destiny's like amplifying anyway. Yeah. So something
did happen with Hutch by the way. Ogre Boy. That did happen.
He's so stupid with his schizo mappings he forgot to attach you
and the starkers to KF for his narrative to work. Well, apparently,
yeah, I don't know. I like like literally he has argued, yes,
that like I am apparently attached to this, but somebody told
him that like there's a layer of separation which is spicy chat
where doc's information gets posted.
I would just love to see any evidence of this. Literally any
evidence at all. Oh, wait, hold on. There is some evidence. Somebody
came in with uh my picture, like the picture they're saying is
me, the new one. Some some picture of that as like an avatar
to spicy chat. So technically, somebody is trying to dox me.
Thank god Desty's. He's continuing to miss. Okay,
somebody tried to dox that photo in spicy chat. But I don't think
that was like Cleman or me. That would be weird. Huh. Is directly
part of it. I >> believe that person got banned, but I'm
not sure. >> I guess Chud Logic just doesn't care about
any backlash or having it attached to a server. He's pretty much
like Joshua Moon in that sense. Um, null. Sorry for doxing you.
>> I think Chud would be pretty I think Chud would be like
livid if people were just doxing people in spicy chat.
>> I've been looking how they behave the last few days.
And that spicy chat community is incredibly militant. Any post
that gets linked there, you can see the same names commenting
and brigading. If they link a stream there, you can see the same
names like up chat and then spinning weird narratives.
Does Destiny Hold on.
If If we just took that, okay, we just took that and we disconnected
it from the community that's already been referenced. How would
any of that not apply to DGG chat and them embedding streams?
Can we can we get any distinction here at all?
Any backlash or having it attached to a server? He's pretty much
like Joshua Moon in that sense. Um, nulling
you.
I've been liking how they behave the last few days and that spicy
chat community is incredibly militant. Any post that gets linked
there, you can see the same names commenting and brigading.
Never happened with a tweet that's posted that's critical of
Destiny in DGG chat. It's never been brigaded ever. >> They
link a stream there. You can see the same names.
Stream gets linked. It's never been Are we serious? Is this actually
Is this guy a idiot?
How do you not how do you not just do the the self-critique there
and say, "Wait, could this be applied to my community?" Yeah,
obviously it can
literally talk about that today because of the Quinio Discord
pirate software. I have no idea what you're talking and then
spinning weird narratives.
Yeah, but it's like it's it's annoying and weird because like
people like weaker people like Dioro will get pulled into this
like sphere and then all of these people become this like focus
of uh like this vector for attacking anybody that they deem as
being like an
Weaker people like Doro get pulled into this sphere and influenced
and they become a vector to attack people. Is he trying to imply
that like Nicholas Dioro didn't really have criticism of him,
but he was just getting like mind by spicy chat? Is that what
he's trying to say? Like actually, no. Nicholas Nicholas should
never he would never have gone after me if he wasn't totally
minded by by Chudlo Logic.
Guys, that's obvious, isn't it? Nicholas would never have gone
after me if he wasn't mind read by Chudlogic in his community.
Huh? Narratives brigading. If they link a stream there, you can
see the same names like up chat and then spinning weird narratives.
Yeah, but it's like it's it's annoying and weird because like
people like weaker people like Dioro will get pulled into this
like sphere. Oh,
fantastic point.
Right.
Right. Weak-minded because he's hopped off of being like friends
with Dan. Right. He's hopped off of being friends with Dan. He
was like, "No, no, no. I don't like doxing actually, guys. And
got Willie to cancel that podcast.
Dude, dude,
I totally forgot about that.
Such a It's all amazing clips. Yes, this person has zero self-awareness
at all. No self-awareness. We haven't even gotten to the part
where the entire Twitch anti-semitism
campaign started with Dan saying, "Hey, Dan Clancy, I've got
pictures of you and your kids at the beach. What are you going
to do now? I've got all of your
Uh, what?
That's how this started. That's how this whole thing, the bad
empanada connection to these people and Hassan, that's how that
all started. By the way, these people were very loosely, a lot
of these people totally disavowed bad empanada. But it turns
out when you get the bad empanada on Destiny's side going after
all of these people, they turn to someone they don't fully understand.
Okay? They turn to
Where's the Alfred? Where's the Alfred and Bruce Wayne scene?
Okay.
Uh,
they don't fully understand.
Okay, Bad Empanada is actually the Joker. Okay, Bad Empanada
is actually the joke. Uh, this is Dan, by the way. He's like,
I knew they wouldn't go down without a fight, but I didn't I
didn't think they'd do this whole thing here. We don't need the
whole thing. Okay, some men just want to watch the B world burn.
That's how it ends. All right, we don't need the whole thing.
But like, it's actually it is just
they're doing they're engaging in the same behavior. They're
going back and forth and this these links weren't that strong
before the Twitch anti-semitism thing before they started going
hard on Hassan and and Twitch in general >> and [__]
And then >> I'm not become this like focus of uh like this
vector for attacking anybody that they deem as >> Oh, we'll
go back to Nicholas being >> People like Dioro will get
pulled into this like sphere. annoying and weird because like
people like weaker people like Dioro will get pulled into this
like sphere and and then all of these people become this like
>> focus of uh like this vector for attacking anybody that
they deem as being like an enemy.
Oh yeah,
Destiny talking about you and Chud. So apparently Nicholas is
just a vector to attack other people. Nicholas doesn't have any
sensience of his own. He's just a vector to attack other people.
Who's he been attacking this whole time? Oh, all of your enemies,
Destiny. Wow, that's weird. That's almost like you're projecting
something there. Do you feel like you've been controlling Nicholas
to attack your enemies directly for months and months and months
or something? Very interesting. Yes, we get the Pepe Silva thing.
Uh I I hesitate to use this cuz I do believe
the person who linked this warned me that this uh apparently
got posted on Kiwi Farms. This will this will prove the link,
guys. The fact that I use an image that was also posted on Kiwi
Farms, that will prove that apparently there's a link between
these people. It's all connected. It's all connected, guys. It's
It's all connected. It's there. We can put them all together.
We can all We can connect it all. It's all connected.
Okay.
Riyle Justical's editor retweets bada and posts his stuff in
other subreddits. Banana docs a few days ago. How
retweets? I don't have any idea. I I retweet some clips from
Ry on Twitter. I got no idea about that. Um
I'd have to see what he's retweeting bad empanada doing. I guess
I have no financial ties to Riyle and I have no control over
him. Um I I can't tell him what to do. I cannot control his if
he goes crazy. That sucks. That kind of sucks. But like I he
basically posts my on on YouTube for no like for just the money
that he would get out of the channel,
right? Like we don't have a financial tie, but I don't like copyright
strike him because I want my stuff to be on YouTube. That's the
That's the tie we have. All right. >> This is not a direct
endorsement of doxy just works well because disco will always
say things like, "Oh, well, when I retweeted it was two layers
deep, right?" They'll always like
Okay, that is true though. Wait, you have to actually look at
the facts. Sorry, I'm By the way, I don't even know that any
of that happened with Riyle. I just don't know. Right. I'm sure
Riyle has like a a strong sense of like what he's done is correct
or or right, and he could just explain himself, right?
>> Disount. But anyway, that's why I'm saying like on a
from like a moral level. The only reason that I don't allow doxing
or anything, >> a lot of people that posted the anarchic
thread on KF were probably DJers. Doesn't that implicate Destiny?
According to Destiny, yes,
>> Unlike any of my platforms where it's against QS is
because it's against >> Destiny would absolutely be responsible
for the anthread, any lab stuff that's on there, any Mac stuff
that's on there. Yeah, Destiny would absolutely be >> In
terms of like morality or ethics, I don't give a [__]
about Well, I basically the same I guess I said to Will. I don't
care about any of these people. Um, these people are absolutely
unhinged and crazy. And I and I don't think I'll say this too.
Um,
all of these people are unhinged and crazy. This entire sphere
of people who I've connected through no evidence through just
my skitso machinations,
they're all crazy and unhinged. They might have BPD. They might
be mentally ill. They might be. Okay. All of these people. All
of them. And maybe it's just because I'm a public figure, so
I maybe maybe that's why I take this chance. I think that if
you're going to spend all of your entire life obsessing over
and like covering drama and being so peripherilally attached
to doxing communities, I don't think you deserve. >> So
peripherally attached. So not attached at all.
So not not attached at all then. >> Anonymity anyway. You
should absolutely be unmasked. Everybody should know who >> if
you're going to cover drama, you should be doxed according to
Destiny.
Huh.
What? What's your problem with
What would Wait, what would what would Destiny's problem with
Willie getting docks? I have a problem with Willie getting docks,
by the way. Okay.
Uh, I'm not even going to read that. Uh, get rid of that. I don't
want that in my chat. Sorry, Pensive. Go, don't say like that,
please. No. No. I will literally time you people out.
I'll actually start timing you people
Uh, hold on. You got to go for an hour or something. Sorry, Mark
Carney. You're
Nope. Nope. None of that. None of that. Now you
>> none of that now. >> Ezekiel Snake, thank you
for the five months. Thank you. Thank you. But like he he's arguing
why a bunch of people around him would be complicit, right? Is
he not
like if you could just make these connections. Oh, you have a
positive relationship with this. Oh, you've like cited something
from here. If that's the level, if that's the the the bar to
meet for people to be collaborators, then it seems like, oh,
literally everybody on everybody's connected to someone, okay,
you follow enough degrees, okay, six degrees of Kevin Bacon,
but six degrees of who whoever I wanted docs on the internet.
All of your entire life obsessing over and like covering drama
and being so peripherilally attached to doxing communities, I
don't think you deserve anonymity anyway. You should absolutely
be unmasked. Everybody should know who you are and if they want
to find your address and whatever all the same they do to me
and any of these other people involved. Oh, don't forget that's
part of the part and parcel of being an online figure. So yeah,
Apparently he just gets to dox people. It's part and parcel of
being an online figure. Remember the impetus for him doxing people
is other people getting doxed. I don't understand how this logic
follows. Apparently it's part and parcel being an online figure,
right? But if if someone else doxes somebody close to him, even
though that's part and parcel of being an online figure, he's
going to dox me or queen or I don't even know where he go from
here. Probably looking at chatters, I have no idea.
Like the things he says make no sense. Oh, also he's really he's
so upset that he'll have to dox other people, but he's not going
to let any of those people know that they got doxed either. Listen,
I'm not trying to [__] on you or anything, but your
explanation of their reaction to unhinged behavior reminds me
of when DJ was sapping Vosch around the >> Wait, wait,
wait. I have to listen to that again. >> Their reaction
to unhing nope nope nope nope. Destiny, not trying to anything,
but your explanation of their reaction to unhinged behavior reminds
me of when DJ was sapping Vos around the time of his debate about
the definition of a woman. I mean,
remember all of those harassment campaigns your community like
openly engaged in and coordinated via DG chat? Yeah. Isn't this
like a little hypocritical, Destiny? I mean, I mean, you know,
like technically probably I'm like one of the worst when it comes
to this, but uh you know, no, no,
no. If somebody did that to me, like there was an account in
my subreddit that was like a secret Vosch fan and was like kind
of like, would it be annoying? Sure. But that's not even remotely
on the same level as that. That's not even You can say it's bad
or wrong. I guess if we want to, which is maybe fair, but I wouldn't
even agree with that cuz I know there's gay ops in my um subreddit
all the time, but I'm not saying they're the same. Just give
me a fond memory. Oh, sure. Sure. Yeah. Like people are always
going to ask Turf and do stuff like that, which I mean like if
you find a banner, but bridge building with Daily Wire, etc.
was very good. You got understandably frustrated, but really
only after one interaction with each individual. After two to
three, you start to digging on topics and win people over. You
have to understand that Jordan Peterson and Candace Owens were
committed to never talking to me again. >> So, hold on.
These are the These are the tweets that Riyle has retweeted a
bad empanada. Hold on. Let's see. When When he says Riyle has
retweeted bad empanada, let's see what it is. It is all YouTubers/
streamers who use those bouncy cartoon rant sonas need to be
put into camps now. So, this is me. This is him retweeting something
about me being put into a camp.
Bouncy cartoon rant sonas. This is literally him tweeting something
that's funny because it targets me.
Just to be clear, that's that's it.
And then the other one he retweeted is a response to not so erodite.
Okay, it's a response to not so erodite. You work for the guy
who revitalized Fuentes's career, but also he hasn't genocided
hundreds of thousands of people. You
So this is not like an unhinged. Apparently these are what make
you worthy of being included in the bad empanada sphere and doable.
Is this
my brother?
Do you see how he just he totally lies, right? He just totally
lies about like what's going on. Well, apparently he he retweets
Ban and Panata. Doesn't it matter what gets retweeted?
Does it not matter at all?
Okay. See, that's why we just look into stuff and all of his
claims fall apart because he doesn't care. He's just going to
lie. And nobody in his audience will ever check him because they
are losers. And they need somebody who makes them feel like they're
not losers. And the best they've ever found online is Destiny.
So Riyle was bad empanada the whole time. Apparently,
let's see. I don't know if there's more to this video. >> A
nice conversation. I would think in retrospect, I think I would
have rather just not talked to them or had that first conversation
been hardcore. Um, the more I think about it, the more I am actually
like really really bothered. I actually hate the fact that stupid
on my subre that posted this has been destroying my mind. Um,
and I think that is actually true that a lot of people just don't
really view Trump as being that bad. I think a lot of people
just don't view the Trump stuff as being that bad. They just
don't. Um, >> is he done with this? He might be moving
>> The boiling
It's the boiling pot frog.
Looking at this girl's Twitter will help him feel like not a
loser. Hold on.
Hold on. What is this? What is this?
My DMs are open for apologies. Yes, queens. And any other calculation
to my intellectual superiority?
MAGA will never accept the fact that Trump is a kitty because
they'd be too depressed that Trump didn't their kid. I'm going
to be real, man. And I think a lot of the right wants answers
as well. Unless you're talking about the extremists and then
well yeah obviously there's going to be they're going to be Trump
doesn't release the Epstein files. Would you say it would have
been better to vote for Camala? Let's call about it sometime.
I'm streaming for three more hours today. Wow. Aite built a bridge.
Oh my god. To a another predator. Another another person who
doesn't respect consent. Another p total piece of who totally
lies about everybody around him all the time. Let's go
connect these narcissistic sociopaths. Let's go.
Bridges built. Let's
awesome.
Awesome. You love to see it. You love to see it.
Oh, you love to see
We're going to get We're going to get everybody with like a weird
We're going to get them all on the same all on the same team,
guys. Okay. We just need we need to get every consent violating
brick pointing in the right direction and we're gonna have a
bridge. All
for TeeOne alleged for Teone alleged. Okay. Alleged consent violations
should be clear. Do you ever review that conversation between
Teone and Aerodite? Nope. But maybe we will. Maybe we will. Maybe
we'll go and we'll be very, very, very unhinged and obsessed
and go after
Limited immunity deal for Aeronite.
That is how this all ends. Limited immunity deal for not so Aeronite.
Okay,
but why would anybody compare you to Glenn Maxwell? I can't think
of why. Oh my god.
H. Okay. All right.
I think that's it for for that. I think that's it. Hold on. Let
me see.
Is this the same one? This is the same one, isn't it? >> I
can't believe no one is talking about that ninja.
Wait,
hold on. That's unrelated. Do you mean they don't view it as
bad or don't understand that it's
>> I think this is over, right? >> And the topic,
the main topic today is >> Oh, hold on.
>> There was a guy who wip
>> What is this? This kid was on stream yesterday saying
he desperately wants to debate you over this Willie Max docs
thing. Yeah, but I don't care. This is Hold on. It's going to
be an Aiden clip. Oh, it's going to be an Aiden clip. >> Technically
correct on >> I just I scanned and saw the hair. I saw
that clearly Destiny's not going to want to talk to Aiden though
because he is going to get PTSD about talking to Britney Simon.
Okay, that's He's going to be He's going to be like, "What the
fuck?" Okay, Britney, if you want to talk to me, you don't have
to get a change. You can just talk to me. You can just message
me. Okay. every point, but on the concept, on the macro, everybody
knows that he's wrong.
>> Destiny Destiny is trying to explain this is literally
Destiny
is going to repeat the exact critique right-wingers have of him,
right? If I if like he's going to Yeah, he's going to bog this
down in little pedantic points because he's going to go, "Oh,
well, factually, you can't demonstrate this. You couldn't quite
demonstrate that." And he's going to bog it down. But if you
look at the macro, if you look at everything put together, if
you look at the constellation,
then you know that I'm correct, right? All we have to do is look
at everything in aggregate and then it's obvious I'm correct,
>> right? This is this is the exact thing he mocked every
right-winger for with regards to January 6th or QAnon, anything
to do with Trump, right? He mocks them all for this exact same
reason. He's about to explain why he would lose a debate to Aiden
on the substance of this or anybody on the substance of this.
And it's because, well, guys, listen. Maybe they could prove
that I like can't connect things. Maybe they could show that
I don't have evidence for anything I'm saying. But in aggregate,
in aggregate, okay?
In aggregate. They all know I'm right. They all know I'm correct.
In aggregate, guys, they all know. They all know it's all connected.
In aggregate, they know. They know. They know. They know.
on the macro. Yes, you quote something Canadian Willy's docs
that Tiny also reposted uh that Willy Willie also did. No, no,
no, no, no. I retweeted Pensive Goat. To be clear, I retweeted
somebody who was criticizing Destiny's hypocrisy on doxing, right?
who themselves was doing so via quote tweet of somebody who was
making a comment on a clip from Quean where Quean was criticizing
Destiny on his hypocrisy on doxing via Destiny's quote tweet
of Gatof Fumador where Gatof Fumodor included some pictures of
Willy's docs and Destiny was saying this is bad or Destiny was
saying nothing done against bad empanada would be bad. Oh the
Gatop Fumador clip is from a bad empanada video. Okay, that's
how far you have to go down that hill to understand like where
the actual information was. And it's all, by the way, from Destiny's
quote tweet. That's where we all found it was Destiny quote tweeting
this and blowing it up for everybody.
So, I don't I don't I don't accept any responsibility for that
at all.
And and Willie Willy's been posting like, "Well, he removed it,
so thank you to him for that." No, I didn't. Dickers removed
it. I would have left it up there cuz I don't think I did anything
wrong. I don't think anything wrong was done there.
I thought it was literally in the tweet you retweeted based on
how DG portrayed it. No, it was not. It was literally the tweet
I retweeted had nothing of that information. The quote tweet
from that person had a picture of the Gat Fumodor Destiny retweet,
right? Was on Queman's screen. So, they're commenting on Queen
stuff and Quimman was commenting on the the Destiny quote tweet,
but like the screenshot doesn't include any information about
Willie. You'd have to click into that and then you'd have to
watch a bunch of the clip to see
So, the tweet as it was on my timeline has no information about
Willie Mack in it. No doxing information, no PII.
And Willie, by the way, didn't message Dickers to get that taken
down. Willie just see about it publicly, thereby trying to make
it seem like I was amplifying it when he knows that it's all
commentary on Destiny's quote tweet and Destiny was the one amplifying
it massively because Destiny's trying to get a gotcha on bad
empanada and doesn't give a about Willie or his wife or his wedding.
[__] you, Willie. Okay, according to Destiny, it's
you your wife everybody cuz I need to make a great tweet about
bad empanada. That's how Destiny sees the world. Okay, so you
keep defending him. You keep coming after me if you want, but
this is the guy who's trying to with your wedding.
I don't don't get it twisted, buddy. Okay. I don't I don't want
your wedding up. He does. Hey, this is a game where he's going
to be. >> Destiny ran from dickers today. I wish Destiny
would unblock me so I could quote tweet his
What is this?
Destiny, I'm streaming. I'm in I'm in stream disagreements. Read
JTO tweet. I am the guy who wrote the original tweet. Oh, did
Destiny not want to talk to him or
Let's see what his cope is on Aiden >> This is the thing
because like this is a game, right? This is a game where he's
going to be technically correct on every point, but on the concept,
on the macro, everybody knows that he's wrong. Where it's like
if you look at the exact tweets that Justical tweeted, you'll
actually see that there was actually no ducks in the exact when
you look at the quote tweet. And that when you look at his chat,
anybody that posted docs is
>> So
yeah, when you look at the facts, when you looked at when you
look at the facts of the matter, uh it's clear he didn't dox
him. Yes, that is everybody's argument but yours, Destiny. But
when you look at the aggregate, if you look, guys, if you look
at the aggregate, okay, if you look at it all put, if we put
it all together, if we put it all together, it's it's clear that
he doxed him. We put it all together banned immediately and he
disavows all forms of duing and it's like technically you're
correct on everything.
Why
dude? What? What? There's no way. There's no way. Is it that
all of the doctors and all of these people all seem to be in
that community though? Like isn't that kind of a weird all the
do isn't it weird dude? He is actually queuing on. Isn't it weird
how like these people Isn't it weird how like all of the billionaires
go to the Bilderberg meeting and isn't it kind of strange that
like the people with the money seem to get policy dictated in
their favor? Isn't it like strange? Isn't that weird? Isn't that
odd? He's actually just doing it. He's actually just doing it.
coincidence. Why isn't it kind of like spread who who are the
doctors in my community? Who are the doctors in my community?
Why doesn't he say the names
evenly throughout the space? Why does it seem like all of these
people seem to be >> Do you know Do you know what the actual
connecting thing is? What if he had any idea of social connection?
Any idea how social groups operate? Um, it turns out the connecting
factor is we all think you're a weird freak. That's the connection.
We hang out and we were all present for like all of these leaks
happening and we all think you're a weird freak. That's the connection.
You solved the conspiracy, bro. We all think you're a weird freak
who looks sort of like their haircut and their boutique. Make
them look like a not accusing you of being a by the way. You
just look like one. You look like you have an unmarked van and
you sit outside of schools. Okay. Not but I don't think you do
that. I'm just saying you look like you do that. Okay.
You didn't used to be this blatantly dishonest. I don't know.
I want to go back. Like I feel like going back and watching things.
It's so transparent.
It should be so embarrassing to speak like
He he is actually doing his impression of like a right-wing conspiracy
theorist that all of the doctors and all of these people all
seem to be in that community though. Like isn't that kind of
a weird coincidence? Why isn't it kind of like spread evenly
throughout the space? Why does it seem like all of these people
seem to be in your camp and this is ignoring all of the collaboration
and side discords?
You are trying to dox me yourself.
Dan openly doxes everybody who crosses him. What are we talking
about?
Yeah, I do have doctors in my Discord. Dan's still in my Discord.
Yes, I do. You got me. I have Dan in my Discord. I do have doctors
in my Discord. [__] Of which is hard to even track
all of it. And it's ignoring all of the gay apps in the multiple
accounts because I know of at least one person um if not two
like 50/50 on one of the other accounts who post both in the
Kiwi Farms thread and in the um Anistical Discord server now
in a side Discord server because of reasons. But like there's
so much like collaboration. Huh?
Is he talking about Sock Dem Incel? the guy who like hates me
and is banned from my community was banned like almost >> and
information exchange. But like this as long as you have this
hardcore like we disavow and we abandon this had a direct retweet
you bro like it's so stupid it's so so I don't need any connection
I will never have this is him by the way saying to all of the
people around him I hope you guys understand right audite counterpoints
you can never turn on this guy or he will publish anything he
can about you right I hope you all understand that the actual
thing I've done wrong is be against this person and the second
you turn the second you step out of line he will
He'll use anything he can.
That's just so transparently obvious here, right? He doesn't
need a connection. He doesn't need any actual pretext. He will
make up whatever he needs to go after you if you turn on him.
Is so unbelievably unserious. >> In his mind, he's probably
going to he's probably going to I would love to debate Destiny
on this. I would love love love to debate Destiny on this, bro.
Is Destiny going to run again or is Destiny knows that he has
to run, right? >> It seems like people are justifying JTO's
docs because of the Willie drama. Do you think he should? Yes.
100 if if this is like a widespread thing that people are using
as a wider justification. 150% he should clarify that. But also
that justification doesn't really work since Destiny was looking
for JTO's docs and inciting people to do so long before Willie
got doxed.
Oh, that by the way, some people bring up that screenshot from
Chud with the TDD thing. Right above that conversation is me
discussing with Destiny or sorry Chud that Desi's like saying
he's going to try to dox me and Queenman
like right above that. It was literally like that day
just so you know. So like when I'm like
it's obvious [__] it's obvious that it's this guy.
He's a loser.
Five $5 from plants. Glad you're wearing your nice shirt today.
This is my nice shirt. This is just one of my casual ones. I
appreciate it nevertheless.
>> Okay. I wasn't trying to emulate his voice before hearing
it. Okay. Sorry. >> I don't like to pick outfits. So, if
you just do like a polo jeans, nice watch.
>> Whoever sign up Destiny into watching Aiden comment
on fashion.
Okay. I can't think of a greater torture. You won. You won. That
person's a winner. Okay. It just works. Part of the issue in
my view is saying this is just evil Republicans as they always
have been when I really feel comparing Bush and Trump are legitimizing
a long time because I'm because it's coming up now and because
of Willie. Why is he saying that? Um probably because I'm because
it's coming up now over the Willie stuff, but also because keeps
pretending like the other stuff posted isn't him.
I guess.
Admit that the doc is you or I'll keep doxing you. Admit that
this is you or I'll keeping you,
brother.
just let me you and I'll stop trying to you, idiot. Just let
it happen. Just let it happen. Guess I just made all of these
accounts like nine years ago with the same picture and username
and everything. Just a the long con. Oh, >> Are there a
lot of accounts like that?
There was this >> I I pointed out what I thought was really
weird because I have a leak code account,
but there's there's some weird stuff going on there. I don't
know.
I don't know. I'll I'll look into it more and we'll see.
I
We'll see. I asked some people about it. We're looking into it.
Okay. I I have a feeling he's trying to tie some things together
and he's gotten confused and it's going to be quite funny and
could be a lot of content, but we'll see. I'm going to grab a
red. One
Oh, is that it? I think Oh, no, no, no. There's the This clip
will actually be good. Ignorant on every single one. >> Oh,
hold on.
But it's interesting that he'll run from Dickers and Aiden and
everybody, right? He won't talk to anybody any of these people
about it. It's obvious he's he's just transparently like given
up any attempt at principles. Like, it's over. >> Wait,
what is this? Why go all ignorant on every single one of these
lives? Destiny, listen. I like you or I wouldn't be here, but
you need to bring the interviews, Destiny, to these live versions
of your educational classes. I don't understand what that means.
Who has led dictatorship in Peru? Chad will definitely like this.
Age restricted 1 hour and 14 minutes made by a dude who hates
me. This has got it all, folks. Yeah, let me go watch a video.
>> Okay, this is uh this is the bad and banana thing. I'm
going to use bathroom real quick while this plays. Context for
this clip. I don't need context for this clip. I know the context
for the clip. >> Tatip improved. chat will definitely like
this. Age restricted 1 hour and 14 minutes. Uh, made by a dude
who hates me. This has got it all, folks. Yeah, let me go watch
a video about a dude who constantly talks about how I'm a reactionary
fake socialist because I watch people's videos. That seems like
a good idea. It's age restricted, which means there's like to
violations galore in there. Bad empanada. The the cringiest like
classic angry leftist who never shuts the up and is just angry
at the entire planet. You're a propagandist, dumbass. Like, do
it better. Okay. Your your job is to do propaganda. Do it better.
I thought that bad a like you he used to. I think he doesn't
like me because he hates the He's like on board with like the
react gate. He's like, "Wow, Hassan just like reacts to videos
and he's like stealing other people's labor." Yeah, he he does
not like me. I'm never going to watch a bad empanada video on
this stream. I'm just letting you guys know. If you think >> So,
like, hold on. Hassan doesn't like bad empanada cuz bad empanada
was mean to him. Hassan is like a total diva who doesn't take
criticism. Well, wow. Oh, you're telling me this for the first
time? I had no indications of this. I had no idea this was the
case. All right. I had no idea. Hassan's
Hassan is a diva who doesn't take criticism. What? What?
No, no,
no.
No way. You think I'm going to watch a YouTube essay from a dude
literally openly antagonistic towards me watching YouTube videos?
You're out of your mind. Okay. You think I want him to write
like >> why read the question but not answer. No, I was
I'm sorry I sounded like I was being I just don't understand.
Um
I don't understand the question. Why go ignorant on every single
one of these lives, Destiny? Listen, I like you or I wouldn't
be here, but you need to bring the interviews
want that at all. Okay. He would perhaps benefit tremendously
if I did watch his YouTube videos on this channel, but I'm never
going to do that. Okay. Yes, insane leftists do actually make
really good content uh from time to time. I think would be one
of the >> Hey, so is there supposed to be an inconsistency
here or >> better content creators online if you just didn't
have a clear account because he's such a freak, dude. Oh my lord,
he's such a goddamn freak. He is the most insane person. He has
like 7,000 accounts. I just said I have a an official blockade
on bad empanada videos on this broadcast while I'm live. That's
number one. And number two, he's not >> Yeah, it's just
wild.
>> Literally, it's literally just Hassan going I think
this guy's like crazy. I wonder why Hassan after being like totally
gangsted having all of his brought up from all over the internet
from like 15 years ago, right? Tweets he had 15 years ago getting
brought up and used against him. I wonder why he might have been
like, you know what, maybe this bad empanada guy had a point.
Maybe I was not going hard enough on some of these people. I
wonder
apparently Hassan changing his mind on associating with bad and
panata is proof that he is like uh I don't know fake. What was
the principle there? I don't associate with people who are mean
to me was the
I guess that he's violated,
huh? With such a subjective with such a subjective rationale,
you'd think we'd almost expect him to change it at the drop of
a hat. No, >> I wrote the same letters to the MTV. What's
going on? Why don't you care about me? >> Okay. All right.
I think that's uh that's it. Yeah, he's just transparently stupid
about um Hassan. Like, there's no hypocrisy there. Just be clear,
there's zero hypocrisy on Hassan's part there.
I see no hypocrisy. I don't like this guy because he criticizes
me watching TV. Yeah, he was probably right about you. Maybe
you realize now that he was right about you.
I mean, to be fair, it sounded to me like he's saying he doesn't
associate with crazy people. He was saying he's a crazy leftist
who makes really good content.
I wonder if associating with crazy people might seem a little
more reasonable, right? There's this clip from this stream, too.
Crazy. Hold on. What is this? Oh, wait. That's not what I wanted.
It's this.
this thing is so for pulling video clips up. Hold on.
>> Communism and openly endorses terrorism. >> you
won't be seen at all in any capacity in any hypothetical. Even
in a press conference, even if this >> Oh, hold on. I might
actually I thought I remember we could actually maybe check out
some of this. >> You're GG bait because you know that if
you say anything positive even as a hypothetical, even in comparison
to a major magar like Rob Moore that you can't even in that context,
even in that crazy context where the >> it's like this
it's this is the same thing. He doesn't think Hassan is that
bad either.
I
Dude,
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. There's no way. There's no way Destiny
said he would take Hassan uh he would take Charlie Kirk before
Hassan. Is there Is there any way that Destiny could have possibly
said today that he'd take Charlie Kirk over Hassan?
I Dude, I gave him the benefit of the doubt. I said there's no
shot. There's no shot that Destiny would say, "Oh yeah, I'd want
Charlie Kirk to be president over
Oh no.
Oh no. He's completely
It's good.
Dude, apparently he said it. Apparently he said it,
my brother. >> I can't believe that so much insane has
been radicalized. I This is like the This is like the precursor
to the Germany, right? But at least they had like a
Yes, but but Charlie Kirk is gerbles. Yes, it is like that. But
Charlie Kirk is gerbles.
Dude, dude.
much insane has been radicalized. I This is like >> He
said, "I can't believe how much insane been radicalized. This
like
>> I can't believe that so much insane has been radicalized."
I This is like the This is like the precursor to the Germany,
right? But at least they have like a reasonarian communism and
openly endorses terrorism.
>> It's all unironically spitebased reasoning. I know.
I know. It's crazy.
It's Ah, no. It was never like that. No. Axe. No. It was never
like that,
At least they had a reason.
Oh, hold on. Hold on. Wait. >> Right. But at least they
had like a reason. Communism.
>> That is a funny ending to it. But at least they had
a reason. At least in Germany, they had a reason. With Assan,
there's just nothing. I can't think of a single I could I could
understand why you'd vote for but Hassan Hassan
that's got to be clipchimp. Okay, I that has to be clip chimp.
I I just have to go and watch. I have to go and watch cuz it's
it's up here somewhere. Hold on. Can I refresh this? Did I have
the transcript yet? No. Let me get Let me see if I can find the
transcript. I just have to search Kirk. I just have to know on
the Charlie Kirk front. There's no way, right? There's no way
on the Charlie Kirk front we get him saying like, "Oh, I totally
vote for Charlie Kirk." Or, "I totally take Charlie Kirk as president
over Hassan."
>> Kirk is a fascist.
>> Oh, no. No. This is after. Wait, what?
Oh, he watched the callin first.
Why did he watch the callin first?
There's this I don't know why he would have done this >> when
we I'm think I think you when we see like the like some of Hassan's
like pro terrorist >> they're arguing over if Charlie Kirk
or Hassan would be better as president bro just me Jesus is like
okay I'm I just hate you more than pretty much anyone like you're
demon and so that like I could I could sniff it in the conversation
you were having like that's where he was coming from where he's
just like I like a person like because of comments like that
like I just hate you more than anyone else. Do you think similarly
about support for BB Nyahu? >> I'm sorry. Do >> you
think similarly about support for BB
>> In like similarly in what regard? >> If you support
hatred like if you support Netanyahu similar to if you support
the Houthies what's woring the Houthies or support? >> The
Houthies. It's that's so easy. As much as you like or don't like
Israel like the Israel political establishment is constrained
by the political realities around them. The big the biggest issue
like
how are they con where's the constraining dude? It's listen the
constraining is if they the constraining is you know it's a slow
ethnic cleansing instead of a instead of an a genocide. Okay,
that's the restraining. All right,
people will point to Netanyahu as doing unhinged. Netanyahu will
go as far as he can but not any further. So like if you have
a US president that's restricting his action to some extent then
the
>> what happened? Where was the action restricted? Where
was it restricted? Where was it restricted? >> Political
system will follow and they have their own internal constraints.
Um the Houthis operate fundamentally on a totally different
in a totally different way. >> But hold on, the Houthis
are restrained by reality and the fact that they do not have
the weapons or the ability to cause harm in the same way that
Israel does. >> If you're going to say that restrictions
and con being constrained are enough to make somebody good, then
the Houthies are far more restrained than BB Netanyahu or the
Israeli government are.
That's just obvious on its face. Reality, economics, these things
constrict the Houthies.
I mean, I guess we can run the argument back of like, well, they
can they have I wouldn't even say they can less people because
isn't the population of Yemen isn't like million people? How
many people live in Yemen? 39.4 million people. So, that's not
even necessarily
>> Like, it's the same level of support. Like, yo, go or
go Nah. >> Sorry. Go Houthies or go Nahu. >> Um,
oh yeah, goies. Um, >> what's worse? >> Worse, morally
worse. O >> shouldn't even I can't even believe that this
is like delusional. If you've gotten to this point, you're so
lost.
>> For me personally, it's going to be the Houthies, but
it's just that personal connection. I think morally, I mean,
it's probably >> I think at least in this respect, even
taking your view, it's kind of a wash. You just said morally,
it might be >> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Uh, Kirk,
who's this? Was this? >> I'm not coming here to tell you
that Connor is correct. I'm telling you to say I don't feel like
you were giving him the consideration. >> Okay. But I want
to know what you think, right? So, you you said you would vote
for Kirk before you vote for her. But I'm also admitting straight
up to you that that might be colored by personal like it might
be colored by personal things, right? It might be. It would take
more analysis. >> Is Pisco still collab with Destiny? I
have no idea. Pisco Pisco's leaning after this. I guarantee you
is going to be we should just debate, right? That's what he's
going to think.
>> I right now I will tell you I would go Kirk, but that
might be colored by personal reasons. It certainly might be.
>> All right. Well, can we can we discuss it a little bit?
So Sure. >> Yeah. So in terms of support for terrorists
or support for bad people abroad, I think Kirk supports Netanyahu
and that's bad. Hassan supports the Houthies and that's bad.
Uh would we call it a washer? Do we say Nyak is worse? At least
taking your view. I don't think I can be agnostic about them
and say at least in terms of magnitude they're both bad to do.
Why would you unless you were willing to make a strong argument
that support is maturely worse than support for Nanyahu? I think
that at least in your mind it should be a wash. And so can you
name me on some aspects other than like support for demons abroad?
Like what thing do you think Kirk is better than Han on?
Um, I think like it was what I opened with, right? Like I think
that there's like some pillars of our uh >> Is Destiny
going to comment or is he just going to like listen and say nothing
and just go, "How I can't I can't believe we've gotten here."
Is he going to give an opinion? I thought the whole point would
be Pisco asked the question, you give your answer and let this
guy answer that would be left over after after Kirk got done
with it. I don't think would be left. >> You think Kirk
would support like a like if you were president? Sorry. If if
Kirk if Trump tried to take over the country and he was successful
in installing dictation, do you think Kirk would support it?
If Trump were to take over the country and try to install dict
would Kirk support I I would say he probably would. >> Yeah.
So I don't I would say like there's a highlight. >> The
really easy thing here is just Trump versus Han,
>> right? If you if you think Hassan is anywhere near as
bad as Donald Trump in any capacity, you're
believing that like dude, the whole Kirk
>> Yeah. So I don't know like I think I see the likelihood
of
you know support for a fascist takeover for Kirk is quite high.
Do you like but I feel like the issue I'm having here I feel
like I could just flip the question and the answer at least.
>> Yeah. I mean Hassan would support an authoritarian takeover
from a leftist regime as well easily. 100%. >> My eyes
is at least at bare minimum the same. Right. Like if we do you
think Hassan would support would would Hassan support like the
um the installment of like a communist dictator. I think
>> hold on hold on hold on hold on. >> We're operating
in reality though. We're operating in reality.
I know the constraintments of reality are tough, but in the current
political climate, which one is worse?
Obviously, the guy where the right has like a actual fascist
hold over your country.
>> Yeah, of course. >> Possibly. But maybe that's
a watch, too. I mean, like I think maybe all watches out the
difference is the difference is I think Assan has better people
around him. He has bad people around him, too. But he has some
group of people where he feels a connection to them um that are
tethered to this earth, whereas Kirk is around the worst demons
in the entire American political system. So, are we doing like
a Trump turn one versus Trump turn two analysis?
>> H Well, technically Lauren Southern is on the right,
so I can't say they're all demons. The the woman I love is on
the right, so I can't really say they're all demons, I guess.
What the is this? This
concerned look at saying the people around Charlie Kirk are evil.
Are you
This is your guy, Kenstyle. This is your This is your guy right
here who's like, "No, what are you saying? All the people around
Charlie Kirk are bad? What are you talking about? This is your
guy. He's so spitebased. He hates Pisco so much that he's about
to start arguing." No, there's some I'm sure there's some nice
people around Charlie Kirk. Charlie Kirk hangs out with some
really cool
>> This is here like in Trump one, at least there was like
sane people in the room every once in a while. >> Uh yeah,
I think like except for Kirk. >> Who are the same people
in the room for Hassan? he's going to have around him parts of
the Trump coalition. >> And I just don't see like, okay,
so maybe Hassan, if given complete ultimate
>> people destiny thinks are friends, too, like Adam Freeland.
That's the funny >> Would institute a communist dictatorship.
I'm not sure. I think, you know, he's definitely more apt to
do it than any like normal Democrat, for sure. Um, but I don't
know. I just don't like to to say that you know for certain that
like Kirk is more preferable in terms of the fascist. >> That's
what I'm telling you. Like I'm telling you very clearly this
might be colored by personal experience. might be like for like
I don't want to you know sorry to take it back to this again
but
>> Destiny's just watching he's not even commenting cuz
he knows that if he makes any comment that backs up anything
other than his facial expressions Piscoll will rake him over
the coals and he will get completely in the marketplace of ideas
so he can only sit here and go that's weird that's a weird thing
to say I can't believe how far we've gone cuz he just has to
sit here like a little and watch Pisco totally own him um what
like I would I mean there's no universe in which I would argue
that it's obviously horrible that um
>> talking about
>> cuz I think we agree. >> Switches over to the
debate. Okay. >> I think we agree. Hang on. Let me just
popped out. >> Sorry, my chat's me the off. So, >> what
were they doing? They're like, "We okay with corruption." >> Yeah,
they're like they're like, "Yeah, we love nepatism. Cronyism
is my
>> Having the right last name and becoming a consultant.
>> Oh, you going to watch it from the beginning now? [__]
>> Have you ever seen Sopranos? >> Just to be clear,
that's not what nepotism is. Nepotism is not when you're known
as being part of some other family or whatever and then you get
hired as a place because of your connections or whatever else.
Nepotism is like when your family members get you a job because
they either like work with the company or they put in a good
word for
>> Actually, nepotism means like when when your family
owns the company, you get a job because of that. Does it mean
like somebody else gets you like you get a recommendation from
your dad or something, you get the job? That's not what that
means. Actually, >> they get you hired like that. this
the idea that nepatism is oh wow wait you're part of this family
that are known for this thing or whatever oh you know like you
got some skill set or whatever else because remember Hunter Biden
had a background in all this as well like the guy was the head
of the whatever
>> I I don't even part of the USA and he' like been on
boards and before it's not like Hunter Biden just walked in randomly
and got this job um like having a renowned name and then having
like work that's attached to that name isn't doesn't necessarily
count as nepotism unless you can >> he doesn't have a renowned
name on his own He openly admits that all of his is due to his
dad. He like he's totally understanding of that. Dude, we need
to go read that Biden, Inc. article from Politico that that um
that profile they did. It explains like exactly what Hunter's
attitudes are. Hunter is like Hunter knows that all of his wealth
and all of his fortune flowed down from his dad.
It's not even like that's the worst, right?
Like that's probably always going to be the case when you have
a super famous father, right? And a super famous name. That's
like there aren't other Bidens. There's not like other Bidens
at all basically, right?
This is just naturally what's going to happen. I didn't like
people.
>> Yeah. Like he's got like a JD at Yale and everything.
Like the are we talking about here?
>> The thing they just love they love Biden. This we have
to understand they love Biden. Um Oh, wait a second. This isn't
working. Okay. You know what? We're good. We're good. You're
kind
of low for me. I need to turn you up. Okay. Yeah. Turn me up,
bro. Uh >> chat, let me I'm going to scroll to the >> I'm
gonna get to the Charlie Kirk part here. I don't really want
to watch this guy all day.
uh Kirk. >> Problem right now with cozying up to Charlie
Kirk or cozying up to Donald Trump. The problem right now with
cozying up to Charlie Kirk or cozying up >> okay as between
Charlie Kirk and his son who's a closer >> like this is
it's not even a real >> uh Charlie Kirk for the DNC. I
mean you I can't explain this. >> Who's the closer ally
for the DNC? Charlie Kirk. I knew it was that by the way. I wasn't
sure what we were saying cuz they went to like, oh, if somebody
was a dictator, who would be better? But it's like as an ally
for the DNC, right?
As an ally for the get onto the t-shirt. We did that already.
Go ahead and leave and you can come back in a week. Bye.
>> Anything other than you're trying to >> I'm going
to I'm actually just going to sit on this VOD and watch Destiny
like all day and just laugh at how much of a fallen he is. Thank
you, drama 101. You know what? Actually, no. I'm going to go
from this to Tech versus Aerodite now. Okay, that's what we're
going to do. We're going to go watch that entire Techone Aerodite
humanizing interview. That's what I'm doing now. Thank you. You've
inspired me. All right. Although, I will need guys. Okay. If
you like the content, if you want more of the content today,
you want maybe that Techite interview, I need you to dig deep
into your hearts and your wallets and give a little to the stream.
Okay? There's a couple ways you can do that. You can donate through
TTS. Exclamation boy donate in the chat. We'll give you the links.
There's Kickbot. There's Streamlabs. both work. $2 minimum on
Kickbot. $3 minimum on Streamlabs. Every dollar goes towards
more time on the stream. You see the countdown at the top. You
see the the the meter at the top. You fill up that meter, we
get more hours on the stream. Okay. If you want to give subs
or if you just want to donate more money, you don't want your
message on the stream, you can also sub through kick. You can
sub individually. I love individual subs on kick. That's my favorite
kind of sub. You sub individually, that's a rolling monthly charge.
I get that income. It's predictable. It comes back every month.
All right. I love those the most. But you can also gift subs
on kick. All of it is a 955 split on money. I love it. I need
more of it. Okay, I need more money on the stream. We are
six subs away from another hour on the stream. Okay, let's get
let's get those bars filled and let's get more time so we can
get that entire aerodyite techone interview in. Okay, thank you.
>> Optics right now. >> Did you see Hutch today again
flipped to no on talking to Queenman? Um maybe
J one guide. Someone said get to the T topic. I covered the tea
topic already. That's the thing. That's why I was annoyed. He
comes in and he's like, "Don't talk about this. Talk about what
I want." Yeah. Get the out of here. >> Gummy donated $10.
Woof. Hm. Hm.
>> Thank you very much. Gummy for the 10. Spruce Willis
for the five. The the gifted sub. Five bucks on the stream. Thank
you guys both very much. Appreciate it. >> And then Pisco
Pisco loves to do this thing where he's like, "You guys are just
mad at me because I'm an epic your >> Hold on.
>> Even donated $3 when you face reveal. Any chance you'll
wear a fake beard and a Burger King crown? >> I don't think
so. I would be compelled to say words that I can't say with my
skin complexion if I've ever face revealed. Okay, Reuben. Ruben,
so I can't do that. The power of the crown compels me to say
the >> And then PC Pisco loves to do this thing where he's
like, "You guys are just mad at me because I'm an epic uh objective
person. You guys are He does like a thing he's done for like
a year at least." I've heard him say this.
He does a thing where he's like where he's like I'm an epic logic
per uh Charlie Kirk >> with a DNC. I mean you I can't explain
this by anything other than you're trying to optics right now.
You know you >> and then Pisco Pisco loves to do this thing
where he's like you guys are just mad at me because I'm an epic
uh objective person. You guys are he does like a thing he's done
for like a year
as opposed to Destiny who has done that thing for like 15 years
in a row.
What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What?
This
This guy has never ever gone to say something and thought, "Wait,
how could this be applied to me?" That's never crossed his mind
a single time in his entire life. Okay.
Holy [__] >> Yeah, at least I've heard. You
guys just get mad at me because I'm objective here and you guys
are all brainwashed >> I have to try to do that. No, no,
no. >> Wow. I can't imagine somebody I can't imagine somebody
trying to say that. is a better ally to the DNC than >> like
see that see the see the trick he's playing here and I know he's
smart enough to know this right so it's got >> no I don't
see the what's the trick he just asked who's the better ally
for the DNC Charlie Kirk or this is like saying who's the better
ally for the DNC
right like he's trying to give an absurd hypothetical so that
if you bite the bullet and want to say Hassan is bad you look
as
you possibly can be right that's that's the point that's the
trick I'm giving you a bounding question Destiny's He's well
aware of bounding questions to get the conversation like hey
in principle I am showing you that this is like the logical principle
I'm I'm like employing right so he's giving a bounding question
like hey obviously it has to be somebody less conservative than
Charlie Kirk for us to choose uh Hassan right and Connor goes
no I think I choose Charlie Kirk anyway
but Destiny's pretending he doesn't understand this concept or
he's never he's never heard of it or seen it or done it before
trying to um he's trying to Connor he's playing a trick here
right it's not a matter of who's a closer ally it's what direction
do you head in? >> I've already answered your question
two or three times. >> Like the DNC does not have a problem
right now with cozying up to Charlie Kirk or cozying up to Donald
Trump. The issue is cozying up to crazy leftists like Hassan.
That's the issue.
>> Okay. All right. All right.
>> I again I fail to see which one of these crazy leftist
issues Destiny wasn't on Hassan side of like 5 years ago, 8 years
ago when these elections were being held, right? That made people
swing against Democrats. I'm like trans issues. Destiny was all
Destiny was at the forefront. Destiny's opinion would have been
exactly what the Democrat's opinion would have been on trans
issues >> politically, which is the vote. If you want to
talk about the vote, obviously Hassan is more useful to the DNC.
>> Somehow Connor is getting this 100%. >> than Charlie
Kirk. If you're talking about ideology, which I've mentioned
three times right now, Hassan
wants to see the downfall of the United States. Charlie Kirk,
in my opinion, thinks that he's fulfilling the promise of the
United States. He's a delusional freak, but he doesn't want to
see the downfall of the United States of
>> Okay. Um, Destiny loves that, right? Oh, these people
are too much of too too be judged. Destiny loves that argument,
right? He definitely let that argument be used for anybody else.
>> I got to be careful what I say next. Hang on. Let me
just think just think. >> Oh, boy. We're about to hear
and leave in a minute. And I need to read a super chat as well.
So, but make a good point. Make a good point. >> This is
the DG signaling. I'll respond to it. I'll read you the super
chats and then we can continue this a different day. Okay.
I think you have Hassand arrangement >> I don't. >> Oh
my god. >> Hassand arrangement, right? And then >> They
don't think he's that bad. This is it. This is it. This is it.
They just >> We don't We don't We don't think he's that
bad. I think Assan's pretty bad. I think Assan's pretty stupid,
but I don't think um I don't think having a good relationship
with Hassan is the downfall of the DNC.
I don't think trying to have a good relationship with Hassan
is the downfall of the DNC. I think that's an embarrassing point
to make. And I think saying that if the DNC was trying to reach
towards Charlie Kirk or Hassan, which which of those two creators
which of those two creators audiences could they more easily
court? It's obviously Hassan's. I don't think he's that bad.
>> No, Hassan's pretty bad. Hassan's like I'm sure if I
if anybody ever felt the need to link me Hassan clips of him
saying, I would go, "Oh my god, this guy's a
but I just don't think he's like Charlie Kirk levels of evil."
And Charlie Kirk is complicit in the fascist takeover of your
country. I'm not going to compare Hassan to that because I'm
not a [__] either on that front. I'm not a [__]
on the uh I'm not like ideologically captured. Not even a [__]
I'm not so ideologically captured that I have to like say, "Oh
no, Hassan's worse than Charlie Kirk."
Wasn't Destiny on his Jan 6 arc and going on about the all the
Trump supporters not being American and being traitors? How can
he justify Kirk as better than Han? He literally justified a
Trump supporter getting shot in the head in front of his kids
because he was at a Trump rally.
Charlie Kirk is like the head cheerleader of the Trump rallies.
I don't know. I don't know what to I don't know what to say or
do. I'm just going to make more kitty jokes and kid jokes and
eventually I guess maybe I need other people to do it with me
at some point. I guess it gets normalized and nobody cares anymore,
huh? Is that Is that all it is? Is that like I just I should
just do it more and then eventually it's like just not a big
deal. What's like the most
>> Wait, what did he did he just Wait, what did he just
say? I just missed it. >> I don't know what to I don't
know what to say or do. I'm just going to make more kitty jokes
and kid jokes and eventually I got
>> maybe I need other people to do it with me at some point.
I guess it gets normalized and nobody cares anymore, huh? Is
that
>> Yeah, I actually I actually fully advocate you taking
that path, Destiny. Okay. Yes. Keep talking about kids. Keep
talking about kids, Destiny. That's what you got to do. Okay.
There's no there's nobody on the internet who's basically suggesting
that you might be a already. Okay. We could we could up those
numbers. We We can make everybody think you're a I believe you
can get there. Okay, let's go. Destiny is going to normalize,
guys. That's his mission.
He's going to make you think that habitual consent violation
is just gooning culture. And he's also going to make you think
that are just maps. Okay,
don't get on Destiny for being in those minor attracted person
Discords. Okay, it's all fine.
Oh,
this >> is Is that all it is? Is that like I just I should
just do it more and then eventually it's like just not a big
deal. What's like the most I could joke >> I did one a
little bit ago on some maggot people. I'll just keep doing this,
I guess, every single day and then eventually we can just keep
pushing. >> Yes. Yes.
Oh, he's going to win. Yes. Let's go it further and further and
further and it's
dude. And here's the sad thing. He's getting like abouths. He's
right spamming in the chat. Pisco becoming a Hassan Orbiter was
not on my bingo card. The people in his chat are literally too
dumb to be able to go, "Oh, wait. That seems crazy. Destiny,
Destiny, that seems crazy. Are we really doing this?" Dude, I
I would love to have a conversation with August at this point
and just know where his head's at when he watches like this clip.
And he's like, "Okay,
okay. I guess we're going to we're going to up the kid talk."
Okay. All right. All right. All right.
Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
What's like the most unhinged I could joke about? I did one a
little bit ago on some mag people. I'll just keep doing this,
I guess, every single day and then eventually we can just keep
pushing it further and further and further and it's
I don't at all. I don't. Why? Why the
I think you have a lack of I think you have a devotion syndrome.
>> Yes. True.
>> Yes.
Oh, Destiny's going to feel really mad when he sees when he sees
Connor totally cower away from that statement the second Pisco
is about to respond. Connor literally
himself and cowers away from that statement completely the second
Pisco goes to respond. I am 100% vindicated in Hassan's story.
Why? How? Because I found out they got kicked out of Global Entry.
That that doesn't even that doesn't cut in any way, size, shape,
or form. It's like, well, I know that he got
That's not It's all about the reason he was cut from Global Entry.
What? I know he lost Global Entry because of his political views.
How do you know that?
What? Like
>> all All Destiny would have to do is just argue this.
By the way, I say that you don't know that for sure, too. Pisco
gives a percentage. All you'd have to do is argue. >> Meanwhile,
every piece of evidence cuts against his son, right? Oh, he was
kicked out of Global before he came back to the United States.
Oh, okay. Oh, he was kicked out like two days after uh the Houthies
were declared a a terrorist organization and Hassan was tweeting
out kind of death threats.
>> Wait, but hold on. Those are political opinions, right?
His his opinion on the Houthies is a political opinion. >> Scott
Oh, we find out that um Hassan's stay at um the interrogation
wasn't 2 hours. It was 15 minutes and Hassan didn't even give
a when people corrected him on it. Like every piece of evidence
cuts against him.
That doesn't cut against him at all. The how long he was interrogated
for doesn't cut against him at all. Wait, but if you ask today,
he Pesco's problem is for political views Hassan was targeted
to have this privilege removed. That's the whole point. It doesn't
matter how much of a baby back Hassan is. Not doesn't matter
how much of a diva he is when he overmbellishes every bad thing
that's ever happened to him. That is irrelevant to the fiscal
analysis. Still say, "Oh yeah, I'm 100% confident that Hassan
was politically targeted at the board." He'll still he would
I guarantee he holds that position still today. >> I don't.
Why? Why the I think you have a lack of I think you have Hassan
devotion syndrome. Okay. You have the bottom on him. No, I just
I just took the Trump devotion syndrome and I inverted it. Uh,
hold on. Hold up. Hold up.
>> Yes, Connor. Yes. Yes. Oh. Oh, he um
Oh. Oops.
Oops. Oh. Oh. >> In what world should you,
go. Oh my god.
At what point do you think I I gave Destiny this advice yesterday?
Okay, Destiny's best course of action here is to say, you know
what, Pisco, you were right on this one. And to cut this tie
entirely because every time he fights with Pisco, people are
going to realize Pisco is more correct. Pisco is cooler. Pisco
can actually grow a beard. Pisco is based. Pisco is awesome.
He hasn't violated anybody's consent. Okay, people are just every
time you cover Pisco and try to see about him, people are going
to realize he's way better than you and you're going to lose
more of your audience every single time because Pisco
owns you. Okay, it's over. Pisco has a college degree. Pisco
actually is disciplined. Pisco can actually work hard. Pisco
is capable of great things and Destiny is not. Admit just know
your betters, Destiny. Okay, know who owns you. Pisco owns you.
And if you go after him, you will continue to get owned. >> Cater
to a human being who says that it's good to missiles into civilian
commercial vessels in >> I don't even I don't I can't even
believe that Connor has to ask this question. I It's like this
is such an unhinged insane conversation right now.
>> I'm not saying that's good. No, I'm not saying that
that's good. I'm saying as between Charlie Kirk and Hassan, Charlie
Kirk is incredibly illiberal. I don't even know if Charlie Kirk
has said anything on that level because at least like Republicans
kind of sort of a or at least the ones around Trump kind of sort
of have to kind of play a little bit of a game.
Uh again, we're seeing that like Israel is the dividing line
here for some reason. It's not America. It's not how these people
act in America. It's not how they violate your constitution.
It's not how they support the violation of your constitution.
Right? It is Israel. If you are mean to Israel, that is enough
to say you're not American. Why? I don't know. Why is Charlie
Kirk less a liberal than Hassan? Why is Charlie Kirk better than
Hassan? Well, I don't know. Certainly not for America.
>> How does this guy write a docu? He literally said he
was recording his January 6th documentary lines yesterday. How
the did he do that documentary and go, "Yeah, this Republican,
he's way better than he he's way better than Han. I take him
over Han any day. This guy totally supports this. This guy who
has no problem totally sucking Trump's now.
>> Kirk is not a liberal. Charlie Kirk is a fascist. He's
part of this like youth movement in our country. Uh I I think
he's I think he's so >> by the way, Destiny, the youth
movement that your entire thing on America is based on that he
is evil, that he is destroying America and you're reaching back
out to the youth. You should hate Charlie Kirk, you idiot.
that's like the entire premise of America is Charlie Kirk is
destroying America. He is America.
He has to respond to what Pisco just said. You'd think so.
The socialists and because of the revolution. Oh, whoops. Whoops.
I went too far forward. >> Anything on that level? Because
at least like Republicans kind of sort of a or at least the ones
around Trump kind of sort of have to kind of play a little bit
of a game. Are you getting all emotional? Um, it's 50% real that
I'm like shocked that this person is so incapable of logical
argument, dude. And 50% performance for the stream. And I'm also
I'm going to lose my voice. You consider that Charlie Kirk hasn't
been that mean to Destiny recently. Him and Aronite have like
the same thing, right? Oh, these people are mean to me. That
means they're evil.
Amazing. That was that me? Was that everybody? Okay. Another
example of morals downstream from Politica.
Okay.
Oh, dude. Do you think Destiny is starting to realize that like
these allies are ones he can't defend? Like he's always kind
of like defended his orbiters a little bit, defended forthought
even when it was like a little bit of a hit. Do you think he's
starting to realize that like the Mantis Aerodite counterpoints,
Mantis Aerodite counterpoints, Tom Fury tier of of orbiters,
these ones, Darius, these are the ones where it's like, oh, you
know what? I might have to cut my losses. I might have to go
it alone now. This actually this is not tenable anymore. I don't
know. I don't know, guys. I don't know if this is good.
Do you not think that Hassan actually supports a more authoritarian
type of communism than actually aligns with the DNC?
Uh, yeah. Yeah. No, I think Hassan would probably in his ideal
world do that. But Hassan wants to build towards socialism or
he whatever. Right. Uh here's the other thing. I actually don't
know Apollo's Heights. What I'd like is for every DJer to check
one of the two boxes. Okay. Is Hassan a hyper capitalist, hyper
consumerrist, as Destiny would say, who actually loves capitalism
more than anybody or is he at his heart like a total chic tanky
piece of
which one is it? Right?
You have to pick one. He can't be both at the same time. So,
if you want to say that he's this covert tanky who hides his
power level and he is actually because I believe that he's got
some of those beliefs, but I think they're performance and he
is just a consumer, right? He is like a hyperconsumer guy, I
think that's more accurate, right? But if you want to argue that
he's going to actually institute communism in America, then you
have to argue the opposite. And then you have to explain why
he does all of the um all of the consumer things, all the capitalist
things. You can't he can't be a grifter and somebody who will
overthrow the US government. He cannot be both.
Apollos Heights. Do you think he doesn't understand that other
under like socialism or under communism he wouldn't have the
things he has?
I don't think that's true. I think I think he is way too I think
everything about his personality points towards him being a narcissist
and like a diva and that he could never survive in a world where
he is like equal to his peers. That that would drive him insane.
But that's me.
Charlie Kirk is not a liberal. Charlie Kirk is a fascist. He's
part of this like youth movement in our country. Uh I I think
he's I think he's so >> Yes. So Hassan is at worst like
somebody like a champagne socialist. Charlie Kirk is actively
supporting the like downfall of your country's democracy
and you're going to equate these things. You're going to make
these people equal. Destiny's going to make these people equal.
Really? He might just be self-d
>> Like, ironically enough, part of the reason why people
ended up going with in Germany is because
Okay.
Is this going to be because the socialists were really unreasonable
or something? Is that
He did the thing earlier, too, in that clip. Watch >> He's
part of this like youth movement in our country. >> Uh
I I think he's I think he's so He might just be self-d deluding.
>> How far back could I go? >> Ironically enough,
part of the reason why people ended up going with in Germany
is because they were afraid of the socialists and because of
the revolution
with Lenin and the Soviet Union in Russia. Like that is part
of the reason why people ended up going with the they're saying
this like it's incredible that anybody made that decision. Nobody
likes either of these groups of people.
Is Hassan like Lenin? Is Hassan like actual socialists from the
30s and 40s? Is the sound like that? They're both
Destiny, that means you're
Well, we did see the haircut from earlier in the stream, right?
I don't know who got who got to him and told him like, "Hey,
dude, your hair is like actually you look like you own a panel
van." Okay. An unmarked panel van. You give out candy in front
of a school, right? Isn't that from ear? Yeah. This like comb
over. You look like you own an unmarked panel van. You give out
like candy in front of a school. Okay. So, he fixed his hair.
He ruffled it up or something.
But this is the haircut. He had it going. He actually had it
going earlier as we go further back. Right. Hold on. Let's go.
Let's go back to here. Maybe.
>> Yeah. He really had it going.
Damn.
Okay, we'll go back.
>> Also, Charlie Kirk is more of a quote unquote liberal
like liberalism. Charlie Kirk is more of a liberal than Hassan
is. Even though like Charlie Kirk would support fascism under
Trump. He's already proven as much. He would. Charlie Kirk would
win.
>> Yeah. Yes.
Wait, did he just say the thing that should make him not want
to pick Charlie Kirk? >> Charlie Kirk is more of a liberusal.
>> Also, Charlie Kirk is more of a quoteunquote liberal.
Like liberalism. Charlie Kirk is more of a liberal than Hassan
is. Even though >> Okay, hold on. Let him cook. Let him
cook. Like Charlie Kirk would support fascism under Trump. He's
already proven as much. He would. Charlie Kirk win.
I What? Huh?
Did I miss something? That is part of the reason why people ended
up. >> They're both thing. >> They're both horrible.
>> Also, Charlie Kirk is more of a quote unquote liberal
like liberalism. Charlie Kirk is more of a liberal than Hassan
is. Even though like Charlie Kirk would support fascism under
Trump's already proven as much he would. Charlie Kirk
but made president. Would Charlie Kirk choose fascism on his
own? I'm not actually sure. I don't know. I don't
>> Oh, he's going this way would. But I think these guys
will will go along with it with
>> um this is a very interesting argument on its own. There's
a very
Oh boy.
Would Hassan support fascis? Well, his thing would be that if
Hassan was if Hassan could hit a button and make it communism
in America, Hassan would hit that button. And he's saying, but
if Charlie Kirk could make it fascism in America, he might not
hit that button. I don't know. Here's the thing. Based on their
actual real world actions, I don't know if I believe that. Rhetorically,
I I think Hassan would tell us he clicked that button to make
actual communism happen, right? I think Hassan would tell us
that he clicked that button. I don't know if he would, though.
And Charlie Kirk is clearly taking steps to allow fascism to
flourish in America.
Jtock, should anyone be allowed to run against Democrats? What's
the argument for democracy if everyone who disagrees with you
is evil? I don't think everyone who disagrees with me is evil.
I think there's a lot of Republicans who aren't evil. I think
they happen to have a weird offset, like a weird plurality in
that party where Trump can win the Republican primaries and everybody
else falls in line because they have no spine.
I don't think everybody on that side of the aisle is evil. Never
thought that. And you talked to basically everybody on that side
of the aisle.
Where did you think that I was arguing that they're all evil?
I said Charlie Kirk is evil.
Charlie Kirk is evil. Charlie Kirk sells out his country. Charlie
Kirk's a piece of [__]
Please don't take my arguing for over Charlie Kirk as an endorsement
of Hassan. Please don't. Please don't. Please understand that
I am only doing this in reaction to Charlie Kirk being the other
person.
Here's the thing. I hate Destiny. If you gave me If you give
me Hassan versus Destiny and who could be president, I'd pick
Destiny.
I don't think I'd pick him for like a fascist thing. But like
president or who you who you court for like your political movement,
I'd pick Destiny. And it's not to say that because I hate this
person, right?
But I'm I'm not sitting here like shilling for Hassan.
I think Hassan is just not anywhere near as bad as these people
are trying to make him to seem to like try to I don't even know
what their goal is. I don't know what the goal is anymore. It's
totally disingenuous.
[__] Trump, which is I don't even Maybe that's worse.
It's disgusting. It shows lack of spine. But Assan made dictator.
It's not like Assan is following anybody right now. It's not
like Assan is an excuse to be an actual terrorist comes slurp,
right? He's he's doing it all on his own. sometimes to his detriment.
Charles,
>> no, it's it's all the it's all the Oh, it's all the
stupid um oppressor oppressed narrative. >> Kirk worships
Trump and follows Trump to the ends of the earth. Why? Because
it's made him one of the most prominent political people in the
United States.
>> come slurping ticulous sunset. It's hard to say. We
take a shot though. I need to go get some alcohol and take a
shot. Oh,
hold on. What is this? It's a audio
What if I told you that Steven regularly
>> No, I'm not.
>> All of the enemies of the United States of America.
That That's actually pretty understandable if you're not terrorists,
like actual terrorists. Not even like good enemies. Not even
like China, Russia.
I don't know if I say Russia's a good one, but at least it's
better than Islamic extremists.
That's some that was supposed to be go out of favor after 911.
What the [__]
>> Yeah. Return back. The last thing I'll say is I think
that is this like uh >> Yes. I think that is >> Is
this really the best we can do? This is the best we can do.
Islam Islamic extremists are worse than China or Russia, guys.
He doesn't even s for cool enemies like China or Russia. He simps
for Islamic extremists.
Uhhuh.
It's almost like he has a some sort of principled principled
opposition to the state of Israel. It's almost like you could
almost say this is downstream of a principled opposition to the
way Israel manages the the occupation of Gaza and in the West
Bank. It's almost like that
he does also s for China. Yes. No, he absolutely ss for China.
I don't know why he would say that actually. I don't even know
why Destiny said that. Yeah, he absolutely ss for China hard.
I don't think he ss for Russia as hard. I think people make up
how much he ss for Russia.
Um
but I I do think he ss for China hardcore. So >> at the
end of the day like there's a greater enemy here. >> Who's
your enemy? >> Charlie Charlie Kirk and his ilk bag is
my enemy. >> That's my main enemy. >> MAGA is my
enemy. My enemy also >> is also No, I actually I probably
This is probably the sincere difference between us. My enemy
is also the far left and half of progressivism
>> simultaneously. I have two enemies.
>> Equal. Who's your greater enemy? Well, I think you already
said it. Your greatest enemy by >> by the way, progressivism
was a greater cultural enemy over the past decade. MAGA is clearly
the bigger uh the bigger political threat right now. >> But
but just because like uh Henry Kissinger, he says like it's a
shame that both can't lose. I'm fighting for a center left center
right coalition because I want and I want the far left to lose.
>> Gunhead, you'll pick the fascist over the the commie.
>> Yep. I I unironically like in u in Chile, I will unironically
pick Buchelle and uh >> fascist over commi. I don't necessarily
disagree on that. Fascist over commi maybe. Okay.
But like Charlie Kirk versus Assad, that's pretty easy.
Like you take the worst version of fascism, the hardest version
of fascism, the hardest version of communism. I might take the
fascist over the communists. I'm not totally sure. Okay.
Fascists look pretty cool. All right,
I'll say that. But in the in the actual thing we're comparing
and the actual actions they've taken in the world, trying to
compare Hump and Charlie Kirk is insane.
It's it's just nuts. Buchell and what's the other guy? Um, Chile.
He's the dictator. He's got three people out of airplanes. What
was his name? >> It's so funny that both of these ideologies
like suck so much
>> like communists were supposed to deliver like freedom
to for the workplace and the ability to own your own business
and all this and all their people are poor and starving and they
suck and just massive failure in every level and they all became
authoritarian dictatorships anyway. And then fascism was supposed
to be like the military mightiest racially pure societ. and all
of them like lose their first major war. >> Uh I don't
think Italy's thing was not racial puress. That's not what fascism
was about, right? >> Just like go extin. It's just
>> they
for what they're supposed to be
>> Um talking about >> Pino. I would pick Pinoch
and Buchelle over Maduro and a Yande
All right. What is this? What is this? What is this?
You're like, "But but even cared about Germany or something."
>> Okay.
Okay.
Some super chats. Yeah. Um